Oh, ich habe jetzt meine Kameraabdeckung
von meinem MacBook entfernt.
Ich glaube da nicht mehr dran.
Kameraabdecken ist das Sinnloseste,
was man machen kann.
Wenn jemand Zug auf die Kamera hat,
dann sieht er meine Visage und kann
trotzdem schon sehen, was ich am Rechner mache und das Mikro
ansprechen.
Da kann ich gegen beides nichts tun.
Kannst du das Mikro nicht abkleben, meinst du?
Kamera abkleben ist das Nutzloseste
von der Sensorik.
Ein Laptop, der ist nur offen, wenn er vor mir steht.
Da siehst du meine Visage.
Aber wenn jemand so weit kommt, dass er meine Kamera ansprechen kann,
dann kann der auch mitschauen, was ich auf dem Rechner mache.
Und das ist so viel relevanter.
Und das Mikroansprechen, was vor einem Rechner geredet wird,
ist auch schon mal bedeutend relevanter, als meine Visage anzuschauen,
während ich vorm Rechner sitze.
Was bringt einem das?
Wenn das Ganze, keine Ahnung, ein iMac ist,
der halt im Schlafzimmer steht und immer aufs Bett schaut,
dann kann ich ein bisschen mehr verstehen,
dass man da irgendwie keinen Bock drauf hat.
Aber das ist ein Laptop, der ist nur offen,
wenn meine Fresse davor hängt.
Ansonsten sieht der absolut überhaupt nichts.
Meine Fresse ist viel interessanter als mein Bett, muss ich leider gespüren.
Herzlich willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge 17.
Jetzt können wir aber wirklich schon trinken, oder?
Jetzt dürfen wir zumindest, ja.
Also nicht mehr als letztes Mal, aber sollten wir mal anfangen.
So, herzlich willkommen bei Akronomisierbar Folge 17.
Heute mit Kilian.
Hola.
Und mit mir Hendrik. Und wir haben heute ein bisschen komplizierteres Setup uns aufgebaut, denn wir sind heute sogar zu dritt.
Wir haben uns eingeladen. Marius Melzer.
Hi.
Mit voller Namensvorstellungen.
Achso, das hätte ich dich vorher vielleicht fragen können. Möchtest du mit Namen genannt werden?
Schon okay.
Ist okay?
Zu spät.
Wir schneiden ja hier nichts.
Jetzt schon eine Minute.
Hier wird nicht geschnitten.
Ne, Marius, ich muss zugeben,
ich fülle diesen Podcast und die Gäste
einfach ganz faul mit Leuten, die ich
aus der Uni kenne. Marius und ich haben
zusammen angefangen zu studieren und
du hast immer ziemlich coole
programmiertechnische Themen
am Start gehabt und es waren immer sehr
interessante Gespräche, deswegen dachte ich,
dich muss ich unbedingt mal zu einer Folge
akronomisierbar einladen. Das wäre einfach eine
Beleichterung. Ja, hier bin ich.
Da bist du.
Das ist pure magic hier.
Und worüber wollen wir denn heute mit dir
du bist, und das möchte ich sagen,
Experte oder zumindest
sehr interessiert am Thema
Functional Programming, ein Thema, was ja bei uns in diesem
Podcast noch etwas unterrepräsentiert,
das möchte ich mal so behaupten.
So wie Programmiersprachen.
Programmiersprachen generell.
Nee, aber
da das ja eine Schande ist, dass ich
immer bloß darüber rede und ich mich eigentlich nur
so marginal damit auskenne und beschäftige,
müssen wir mal das irgendwie
von der anderen Seite beleuchten. Deswegen
ein, zwei andere spannende Projekte
am Start gehabt oder immer noch am Start
und die können wir vielleicht am Rande auch noch beleuchten.
Also
fangen wir doch gleich mal an. Möchtest du kurz
ein bisschen was über dich erzählen?
Klar.
Naja, ich
habe mit Hendrik
zusammen studiert und eigentlich ja auch
mit Kilian ein bisschen.
Zumindest haben wir uns doch überschnitten irgendwo.
Und
habe
mich ganz lange irgendwie
gar nicht so mit funktionaler Programmierung beschäftigt,
würde ich sagen, sondern habe eigentlich
irgendwie so ein bisschen
eher verteilte Systeme
dann vertieft gehabt.
Da habe ich meine Diplomarbeit in Stockholm geschrieben
über Stream Processing,
was, würde ich sagen,
verteilte Systeme
mit einem funktionalen Gedanken ist.
Das ist auch ein Konzept,
von dem du mir schon dreimal erzählt hast,
wo ich immer mal konkreter nachhaken wollte.
Vielleicht kriegen wir das noch mit in unsere Liste mit rein.
Ja, können wir gerne machen, ja.
Genau, also generell zwar verteilte Systeme, aber man hat das mit der funktionalen Programmierung schon so ein bisschen mitgeschwungen, würde ich sagen.
Und ich habe halt im Studium irgendwie Heskill gemacht und auch irgendwie so ein Praktikum nochmal vertieft gehabt.
Und lustigerweise, mein damaliger Tutor ist jetzt seit ein paar Tagen mein Kollege.
Sehr gut.
Und ich fand das da schon ziemlich spannend.
Ich habe irgendwie noch nicht alles verstanden gehabt.
Also unter anderem so Monaden und diese ganze lazy Computation-Sache und so.
Und es war mir da zwar so ungefähr klar, was es ist, aber so richtig war es mir eigentlich nicht klar.
Also Monaden sind eher das, womit man Leute abschreckt von dem Thema.
Ja, und Burritos habe ich immer so auf Internet gelesen.
Burritos?
Oh nein, wir sind vergleichbar mit Burritos und das erklärt ungefähr das ganze Konzept.
Ach so. Also jedes Mal, wenn jemand versucht, Monaden zu erklären, wird es irgendwie schlimmer, habe ich den Eindruck.
Das ist so der Kurs der Monaden.
Kriegen wir das ja heute hin, weil mittlerweile habe ich es nicht verstanden.
Denkst du.
Und das ist gar nicht so viel Magie, wie man irgendwie so denken mag.
Genau.
Naja, dann habe ich eigentlich war der Anfang, dass ich irgendwie ein Buch gelesen habe über Idris.
Ich habe irgendwie über Twitter von einem aus dem CCC, Andreas Burg, der hat irgendwie geschrieben gehabt,
naja, hier, wenn ihr mal irgendwie
einen coolen Einblick haben wollt,
irgendwie so in die Welt der formalen
Methoden, dann
guckt euch doch mal dieses neue
Buch über Idris an und das ist irgendwie von
dem
Creator, dem Erschaffer
von Idris geschrieben, Edwin Brady.
Das ist wirklich ziemlich cool.
Das können wir mal in Short Notes tun, wenn ich es nicht
eventuell sogar irgendwann schon mal empfohlen hatte.
Genau. Das war irgendwie
Programming Distributed
Systems with Idris oder
oder Protocols?
Nee, das nennt sich Type-Driven
Programming with Idris, glaube ich.
Genau, Type-Driven
ist halt so ein bisschen wie Test-Driven,
nur dass du halt irgendwie die Typen vorher
schreibst und die Typen sind in
Idris
nochmal krasser als in Haskell zum Beispiel,
was sind nämlich
Dependent-Types.
Alles, was ich von Idris mitgenommen habe, alles ist krasser
als in Haskell und das hat mich einfach mal total geflascht.
Ich hätte den Eindruck, es ist aufgeräumter als Haskell.
Okay, ich habe hier nicht so aktiv mit Idris.
Es gibt auf jeden Fall noch einen guten Podcast dazu,
den ich anderweitig empfehlen kann.
Das war eventuell der Code-Podcast mit einer Folge zu Idris.
Die packen wir mal in die Show Notes.
Okay, interessant.
Also ihr habt tatsächlich auch beide recht,
würde ich sagen.
Es ist aufgeräumter als Heske.
Heske ist halt einfach eine Sprache aus dem wissenschaftlichen Umfeld
und da machen tausend Leute tausend Experimente mit
und die kommen teilweise in die Sprache rein.
Oder das ist auch der Grund,
wieso du irgendwie bei, ich würde sagen,
Haskell-Programm aus der realen Welt,
wenn man mal auf GitHub größere Haskell-Repositories sucht,
dann hat man immer so eine Riesen-Latte an solchen Pragmas am Anfang,
die keine Imports sind, sondern Spracherweiterungen tatsächlich.
Also die sagen dem GHC, also dem Compiler,
wir wollen Haskell, aber wir wollen noch folgende 15 Besonderheiten gerne nutzen.
Das sind dann Makros oder stellt das irgendwie die Sprache um oder was macht das?
Das ist tatsächlich für den Compiler eine Information,
dass der folgende Spracherweiterung mit erlaubt.
Also kannst du neue Konstrukte nutzen dann zum Beispiel.
Teilweise sind das einfach eingebaute Funktionen,
so native Funktionen.
Teilweise sind das Erweiterungen des Typsystems.
Irgendwie solche Dinge kannst du einstellen.
Das kannst du dann einfach nutzen,
ohne dass du irgendwas zusätzlich machen willst.
in anderen Sprachen, die irgendwie
nicht so modular
aufgebaut sind,
entwickelt sich dann irgendwie relativ schnell
sowas wie, keine Ahnung,
was Besseres als CoffeeScript, fällt mir
gerade nicht ein, aber irgendwas, was
dann wieder zu dem eigentlichen
kompiliert.
Das brauchst du halt in Haskell nicht, weil
da kannst du halt einfach sagen, ich mache eine Spracherweiterung
und wenn die es irgendwie
in GHC, also in den
Compiler reinschafft, dann kann die
halt auch jeder benutzen.
So macht das FAS ja zum Beispiel auch, dass sie diverse Features
in Nightly ausprobieren, die kannst du dann halt mit
enablen, wenn du sie ausprobieren möchtest und vielleicht schaffen
die es ja irgendwann ins Table rein. Aber das klang jetzt so,
als ob man Sachen beliebig
mit dazuschreiben könnte, die dann
zur Compile-Zeit mit reingeladen
werden und da die Sprache dann erst erweitern,
also dass die Implementierung davon
mit in diesen Pragmas drin steht oder
verstehe ich das gerade falsch?
Ja, das ist schon, im GSC
sind die alle
implementiert, diese Sprachfeatures
würde ich sagen. Und dann macht man die quasi
schaltet man die bloß an. Genau, richtig.
Ah, okay, das ist doch wie ein Rust.
Cool. Genau, also
Idris ist einfach,
würde ich sagen, Haskell
ein bisschen aufgeräumter,
aber auch ein bisschen krasser, weil die
Typen halt sehr ausdrucksstark
sind. Da können wir vielleicht einfach später nochmal
hinbekommen. Genau, jetzt gehen wir schon
ziemlich tief in das Feld rein,
aber ich meine,
nach 16 Folgen akronomisierbar
weiß ich nicht, wie sehr man noch
das Konzept Functional Programming
zum 35. Mal wiederholen müsste, aber vielleicht kann man das ja nochmal ein bisschen von jemand anderem
erzählen lassen. Also steigen wir doch mal direkt
irgendwie ein. Functional Programming. Wir haben jetzt gerade von Typen geredet, von
Typsystemen und von Monaden und von
Seiteneffekten, aber was macht für dich Functional Programming
eigentlich richtig aus?
Also es ist schwierig. Ich habe mir jetzt im Vorfeld schon mal ein bisschen Gedanken drüber gemacht
Und das Problem ist, alle Sachen, die man irgendwie finden kann, die so eine Definition ist, die werden nicht von allen Programmiersprachen umgesetzt, die man üblicherweise als funktionale Programmiersprachen einordnen würde.
Das heißt, kaum eine Einordnung ist so gut, dass da alles drunter fällt, was man sonst als funktionale Sprache irgendwie verstehen würde.
ich glaube, dass halt irgendwie drei Dinge
ziemlich wichtig sind und
vielleicht kann man ja sagen, wenn zwei
von diesen dreien da sind, dann ist irgendwie
schon sowas wie eine Funktionalsprache.
Eine ist
Purheit, das andere
sind so
nicht veränderbare Datenstrukturen,
so immutable data structures
und
das dritte, ich weiß nicht,
was der deutsche Begriff dafür ist,
nennt sich
Referential Transparency.
Oh, das ist gar nichts.
Genau. Vielleicht gehen wir die einfach
nacheinander mal durch.
Purheit
ist vielleicht das Wichtigste fast, aber
die meisten funktionalen Sprachen sind gar nicht pur.
Also
Purheit bedeutet, dass Funktionen
so funktionieren wie Funktionen in
Mathe. Das heißt,
ich habe irgendwie Eingabeparameter
und ich habe irgendwie etwas, was rauskommt,
was auch strukturiert sein kann,
aber ich habe nichts, was dazwischen
passiert, was
nicht innerhalb dieser Funktion bleibt.
Also man kann sich vielleicht,
ich habe mir das immer so vorgestellt,
dass man irgendwie so einen Karton hat,
der irgendwie um diese Funktion drumherum
hat und da sind irgendwie so ein paar
Löcher auf der einen Seite drin, da gibt man Sachen rein
und dann passiert in diesem Karton etwas
und dann kann man hinten irgendwie
durch ein Loch auf der anderen Seite kann man
wieder was rausbekommen.
Endeffekt, dass eine Funktion
nur über den Ein- und den Ausgabeparameter
funktioniert und keinerlei
Variablen ausweist.
selber tut, je nachdem, wie oft du es aufrufst.
Also das heißt nicht je nachdem, sondern
du machst immer mit dem selben Eingabe-Parameter,
immer den selben Output. Genau, also du liest keine
globalen Variablen ein, du veränderst auch keine,
die außerhalb deines Scopes liegen,
du nimmst nur deine Eingabe-Parameter
und hast einen Ausgabewert und das passt.
Genau, richtig. Also alles,
was die Funktion in der
Zeit tun könnte, kann halt nicht aus dem Karton
raus.
Und das kann halt irgendwie sowas sein, wie
eine globale Variable verändern,
auf die nicht nur die Funktion irgendwie
hat. Das kann sowas sein wie ein
Netzwerkpaket schicken oder
irgendwas auf die Festplatte schreiben, irgendwas
auf den Bildschirm anzeigen.
Das,
was zumindest in der Haskell-Welt
häufig irgendwie zum Thema kommt, ist
Raketen starten. Das kann man sich
immer ganz gut vorstellen,
dass man irgendwie was bauen möchte,
was nicht versehentlich irgendwo zwischendurch
mal die Raketen startet.
Ich verstehe.
Und
da kann man
vielleicht ein bisschen wichtiger,
dass die nicht gestartet werden, als dass
nicht irgendwo eine Variable verändert
wird. Damit kann man sich das vielleicht ganz
gut vorstellen. Das ist auch generell eine gute Angewohnheit,
finde ich. Also umsetzen lässt es ja quasi
in fast jeder Sprache, dass man versucht,
also,
dass man wirklich
versucht und selber sich darum kümmert,
dass die meisten Funktionen halt in der Richtung
pur sind, dass sie halt keine Seiteneffekte
haben. Das hilft
einfach wirklich sehr, dass man
Code so strukturiert, dass er
von Haus aus weniger Bugs produzieren kann,
zumindest die, die auf Shared Multiple State aus sind,
weil man einfach darauf geachtet hat, dass die
keinen State verändern, keinen globalen State.
Aber an wenigen Programmiersprachen kann man
es tatsächlich ranschreiben und dann
ist beweisbar. Das ist natürlich
super praktisch. Und das
erlaubt einem dann formale
Aussagen darüber zu treffen, was der Code macht.
Ja, genau.
Ich habe ja gerade schon gesagt,
das ist eigentlich bei
fast kaum einer
funktionalen Sprache, sodass die tatsächlich pur ist.
Es gibt so ein paar
Leuchtturmbeispiele, würde ich sagen.
Das ist Haskell zum einen.
Die müssen dann halt irgendwie für
Input-Output zum Beispiel irgendwie
Monaden verwenden.
Dann vielleicht nochmal darauf zurückkommen.
Aber ist das wirklich so ein...
Ist das das Kriterium, was das ausmacht?
Weil ich kann mir...
Ich meine, pur ist ja
das Nicht-Vorhandensein
von etwas, was ich mache.
Ich kann ja ein komplett pures Programm
in JavaScript schreiben, oder?
Solange ich nur darauf achte, und das kann man eventuell
mit einem Linter sogar schon ausdrücken,
dass in einer Funktion innerhalb dieses
Buddies nichts angefasst wird, was nicht
durch den Funktionsparameter
reingegeben ist, oder ist das
eine Sprache, die pur ist, schließt
die komplett aus, dass sowas überhaupt
möglich ist? Ja, an sich
schließt sie es aus, ja.
Das ist auch der
Punkt, wieso es da in Heske so einen kleinen
Kniff gibt, würde ich sagen.
ja, also
ist vielleicht ein Workaround, weiß nicht genau.
Du hast halt,
ich weiß nicht, ob wir jetzt schon auf Monaden vielleicht kommen wollen
oder ob wir
da zurückkommen wollen dazu.
Der Punkt,
dass du Monaden
verwendest in Haskell
ist nur eine Folge davon,
dass die Sprache pur ist
und keine
Unpurheit
Und deshalb muss man sich halt irgendwie so ein Konstrukt drumherum überlegen,
wo man die Seiteneffekte sozusagen aus der Sprache auslagert in einer Art Environment,
die dann dein Haskell-Programm laufen lässt.
Und du definierst halt dein Programm erstmal pur,
indem es alle Seiteneffekte irgendwie kapselt als irgendwie eine Datenstruktur, die es aufbaut,
die man hinterher nur noch aufdrüsseln muss
und anwenden muss.
Und dann erst treten sozusagen
die Seiteneffekte hervor.
Vielleicht später nochmal klären.
Ich kann ja mal ganz kurz
einen Versuch starten. Ich hatte irgendwann mal den Eindruck,
in Sprachen
wie Swift oder Rust gibt es
so Rückgabetypen, typische Rückgabetypen.
Das sind Results oder
Optionals und die kapseln
mein Rückgabergebnis und die sind
entweder
Sum oder None oder Okay
Error, aber ich kann die erstmal so in die Hand
nehmen und die kapseln quasi diesen State
für mich weg. Ich kann die erstmal annehmen und dann
später kann ich drüber mappen
und schauen, ob das nun schon was
okayes ist oder nicht. Ist das schon
eine Monade?
Das ist ein Typ, mit dem man
eine Monade machen kann.
Eine Monade ist immer
eine
Verbindung
aus einem Typ und
zwei Funktionen,
die man anwenden kann.
Und das eine ist,
also es nennt sich je nach Sprache
Pure oder Return,
ist eine Funktion,
die nimmt einen Typen
und bastelt eine Monade daraus.
Also zum Beispiel dieses Maybe,
da gibt es irgendwie halt
dieses Return,
würde halt einen Wert nehmen
und würde ein
Haskell
just diesen Wert zurückgeben.
Also sozusagen...
Ein Maybe hat welche Zustände jetzt?
Optional. Also
Just oder...
Also Maybe
ist Just oder Nothing?
Im Endeffekt wie
im Imperativen, wenn du irgendwie
Null hast.
Nur dass dieses Nothing
tatsächlich ein echter Wert
dieses Typen ist.
üblicherweise, wenn du einen Wert von diesem Typen hast,
zum Beispiel maybe int,
dann musst du immer,
oder manche Sprachen schreiben dir das vor,
dass du immer nachgucken musst,
ob da jetzt was drin ist oder nicht.
Ob da jetzt also ein just-int-Wert ist
oder ob das ein nothing ist,
also null sozusagen in einer imperativen Sprache.
Genau, also das ist die eine Sache.
Die andere Sache ist, dass man eine Funktion hat, die irgendwie Bind heißt zum Beispiel,
oder eine Art Kombinationsoperator, die nimmt ein Element von diesem monadischen Typ,
also zum Beispiel so ein Maybe-Int zum Beispiel,
Und eine Funktion, die von dem internen Typ, also von int, übergeht zu wieder einem maybe.
Also möglicherweise auch zu einem maybe int, aber es könnte auch ein maybe String sein oder sowas.
Das heißt, die kombiniert sozusagen das Resultat, was du bisher hast,
irgendwie in deiner monadischen Kette.
Ein Monad ist immer so eine Hintereinanderreihung von solchen monadischen Funktionen
Und so eine monadische Funktion, nämlich
die, die einen normalen Wert nimmt
irgendwie, der vorher in dieser Monade irgendwie
drin war und irgendwas damit macht und
hinterher wieder einen
Wert
von dieser Monade
zurückgibt sozusagen.
Das kannst du hintereinander ketten.
Und bei diesem Maybe ist
das halt irgendwie, da kriegst du richtig
schönen Code dabei raus,
wenn du das
Problem hast, dass du ganz
oft irgendwelche Errors
Sachen abfragen muss. So in einer
normalen, imperativen Sprache
würdest du halt irgendwie so
riesig verschachtelte Ifs vielleicht machen.
Oder würdest du ständig
irgendwie If so und so
dann Return oder so hinschreiben.
Und so kannst
du halt sagen, ich habe ganz viele Funktionen.
Entweder funktionieren die nicht
oder die funktionieren.
Und ich kann die alle hintereinander schreiben
und die alle mit so einem
Kombinationsoperator
verbinden. Und wenn jetzt
irgendeine Funktion in der Mitte mal Nothing zurückgibt,
weil irgendwie das nicht geklappt hat,
dann sorgt eben dieser Verbindungsoperator dazu,
dass der Rest der Funktion gar nicht erst ausgeführt wird,
sondern dass Nothing bleibt sozusagen.
Das ist, glaube ich, der wichtigste Punkt bei Monaden ist einfach,
dass du es kombinieren kannst und dass diese Kombinationen,
also du kannst ja auch sonst Funktionen verschachteln ineinander.
und kannst die kombinieren, je nach Typ irgendwie.
Aber bei Monaden macht eben dieser Kombinationsoperator,
der dazwischen ist, der macht irgendwas.
Und das ist tatsächlich auch schon alles.
Also eine Monade hat erstmal nichts mit I.O. zu tun,
sondern ist erstmal nur eine Art und Weise,
wie ich so, würde ich sagen, Abfolgen strukturieren kann.
Und es gibt, denke ich, zwei große Fälle,
wo man Monaden anwendet.
und das eine ist ein Container, das hatten wir jetzt gerade schon,
zum Beispiel eine Liste.
Ich habe eine Liste oder dann greife ich auf das Ende-Element zu
und wenn die gar nicht so lang ist, dann kriege ich ein Nothing zurück
anstatt einem Just.
Zum Beispiel, ja, genau.
Also ich mache halt irgendwelche Operationen auf diesen Listen
oder ich mache irgendwelche Operationen auf Containern
und diese Operationen kann ich miteinander verbinden
und ich kann halt sagen, wie ich die verbinden möchte.
Und das heißt, dass auch auf einem Typ, wenn man möchte,
kann es auch mehrere Monaten geben.
Auf einem Typen kannst du mehrere Monarchen geben.
Ja, indem du halt sozusagen sagst,
naja gut, für mein Maybe
habe ich jetzt noch irgendwie eine andere Art und Weise,
wie ich es kombinieren möchte.
So zum Beispiel,
wenn da irgendwo Nothing rauskommt,
dass ich dann weitermache mit einem
Maybe 3 oder sowas.
Achso.
Wenn du quasi schreibst,
konstruiere mal künstlich einen Fall.
Ich habe irgendwie eine Liste
einer beliebigen Länge und dann greife ich
mit einer Operation oft
ein endes Element zu.
Und da kann ich ja schon mal daneben greifen, weil ich irgendwie
über die Länge der Liste hinausgreife und das wäre
schon mal der erste Fall, wo ich ein
Nicht-Zurückkriegen würde, ein Negativ-Fall
zurückkriegen würde.
Jetzt vermischen wir gerade Listen und
Maybe.
Entweder benutzen
Maybe oder die Liste
als Basistyp.
Vielleicht ist es tatsächlich
einfacher mit dem Maybe.
und wenn ich zum Beispiel
irgendwie sage, ich habe immer nur
maybe int
weil ich irgendwas mit Zahlen mache und
das kann halt klappen oder nicht, dann kann
ich halt auch irgendwie zum Beispiel
so einen Kombinationsoperator
schreiben, der
halt irgendwie, wenn irgendwo
nothing rauskommt, der dann
nicht die nächsten Funktionen auslässt, sondern
mit einem Standardwert
weiterarbeitet.
So ein Default of irgendwas. Genau, richtig.
Also das heißt,
Monad ist wirklich erstmal nur irgendwie
ein Typ, der diese beiden Funktionen
anbietet und solche
monadischen Regeln irgendwie
befolgt.
Also das sind super einfache Regeln,
wie wenn ich jetzt so ein
Return, also was irgendwie einer
was einen Wert nimmt und
das in eine Monade packt,
wenn ich das halt irgendwie kombiniere,
mit
so einem Kombinationsoperator,
dann ist das das Gleiche,
wie wenn ich es umkehre oder sowas.
Es gibt so ein paar Rechenregeln,
wie sonst irgendwie
Assoziativität, die einfach auf Monaten
die stimmen sollten sozusagen.
Davon kann man
normalerweise ausgehen, dass die
so gelten,
würde ich sagen.
Das ist aber cooler, dass es natürlich,
wenn man es beweisen kann.
Da kommen wir später noch ein.
Funfact am Randebus gerade eben zur Vermischung von
Monaden und Listen.
Die Maybe-Monade
in Swift heißt ja Optional.
Und Optionals waren in frühen Versionen von Swift
implementiert als Array-Listentypen,
als Arrays. In dem einfach
ein ein-animal-mäßiges Array, entweder ist da was drin oder es ist
nichts drin. Das war einfach die Karte,
die von dem zu Grunde lag.
Finde ich sehr cool.
Ich habe mit Jupp, der ja auch
schon mal zu Gast war, ein JavaScript-Projekt gemacht,
wo wir auch mal kurzzeitig Operationen
auf die Art und Weise gemacht haben,
wo wir auf irgendwas zugegriffen haben, das hat was Optionales
zurückgegeben und dann haben wir einfach ein Array mit einem Element
oder ohne Element zurückgegeben.
Das ist ein guter Overgrow dafür, wenn man sowas nicht hat.
In Rust ist das
der Monadentyp in Optional, entweder
Sum oder Nun und das implementiert
tatsächlich Iterator, das heißt
du kannst da Next drauf aufrufen und dann
kriegst du das Objekt raus, was da drin ist,
wieder als Optional.
Auf die Art und Weise kann man das
relativ gut in
so Iterator-Ketten einbauen.
Das ist ja ein
Konzept, was mit dem auch überschneidet.
Ich bin leider jetzt immer auf dieses Listen
versus Maybe
Ding reingefallen, wo du mich gerade korrigiert hast.
Aber im Endeffekt, wenn du so
Lazy-Iteratoren hintereinander chanest,
ist ja relativ vergleichbar
schon mit,
ob ich nur Aufrufe auf Monaden
hintereinander chane. Also wenn ich
eine Liste habe, wo nichts drin ist,
dann habe ich genau den gleichen Effekt,
Nämlich, dass die hinteren Operationen nicht mehr aufgerufen werden
und ich weiterhin mit einer leeren Liste arbeite,
wie wenn ich auf einem Maybe arbeite.
Lustigerweise ist genau der Fall,
den wir jetzt noch ausgelassen haben,
nämlich die I.O.-Monade, die so ein bisschen speziell ist.
Genau, das hat jetzt eine Monade mit I.O. zu tun.
Da habe ich mir aber immer auch schwer getan,
bisher I.O. generell als Seiteneffekt zu sehen.
Es ergibt das auf jeden Fall Sinn,
sowohl das Input als auch Output
oder generell Interaktion mit dem Nutzer irgendwo ein Seiteneffekt ist,
aber ich habe mich da immer schwer getan.
Das, warum ich das immer nicht verstehe, ist,
weil für mich ist IO, ich denke dann an
SCDIO
und das ist halt, wenn du schon
Standard-Bash-Programm schreibst,
ein normales Kommandozahl-Programm schreibst,
dann ist das halt ein Input und ein Output
und Pipen von Bash-Programmen
oder von Shell-Programmen ist ja auch so ein bisschen
ein funktionales Chain,
du pipest das von dem einen ins nächste,
deswegen, was ist denn an IO
jetzt eine Monade?
Also,
vielleicht erstmal, ganz kurz
dazu, wieso man Haskell
überhaupt so eine IOMonade benutzt.
Das hat zwei Gründe, würde ich sagen.
Das eine ist eben, dass diese Sprache halt komplett pur ist
und dass man halt irgendwie gerne eine klare Trennung haben möchte
zwischen puren Funktionen und Code,
der dann irgendwann später IOM macht.
Das heißt, ich kann schon vom Typ der Funktionen ablesen,
ob ich diese Funktionen ohne Probleme zum Beispiel Unit testen kann.
Also wenn das jetzt eine pure Funktion ist,
dann gebe ich da irgendwie eine Kombination von Parametern rein
und immer wenn ich das mache, kriege ich das gleiche Resultat.
Zum Unit testen ist es perfekt.
Und auch wenn ich ganz viele pure Funktionen miteinander verbinde
und habe dann hinterher wieder eine Funktion,
dann hat die eben auch wieder diese gleiche Eigenschaft.
Und das sind ziemlich coole Sachen.
Das ist mir nämlich irgendwie so,
in meinem Diplomobel zum Beispiel habe ich Java und Scala gemacht.
Und da ist mir das echt häufig irgendwie auf den Fuß gefallen,
dass irgendwie plötzlich ging irgendwas nicht.
Und dann habe ich irgendwie diese Klasse mir genommen,
die da diesen Fehler irgendwie produziert hat.
Und dann habe ich einen Unit-Test drum herum gebaut
und es hat alles wunderbar funktioniert.
Und dann habe ich irgendwann mitgekriegt,
mitgekriegt, naja, gut, außer mir, der da sozusagen gerade auf dieses Objekt zugegriffen hat
und irgendwie Sachen mit diesem Objekt machen wollte, hatten eben auch noch andere Teile dieser Software
Zugriff auf dieses Objekt, hatten eine Referenz und haben dann währenddessen einfach mal den Status
von diesem Objekt irgendwie geändert und dann kamen natürlich komplett falsche Sachen raus,
wenn man sich da irgendwie so gegenseitig irgendwie reingegrätscht hat.
Und das kann dir halt irgendwie, wenn du pure Funktionen hast, kann dir das nicht passieren.
Dann gibt es immer alle Sachen, mit der die Funktion arbeitet, gibst du rein.
Dann macht es was damit und gibst es dir wieder raus.
Und es kann nicht sein, dass jemand, der gleichzeitig auch diese Funktion aufruft,
dir da reingrätscht, weil irgendwie im Hintergrund sich der Status geändert hat.
Java ist ja eine objektorientierte Sprache.
Und das ist so diese Stelle, die du gerade beschreibst, oder so ein Szenario, was du gerade beschreibst,
Also das, wo Functional Programming und Object Oriented Programming diametral sich gegenüberstehen.
Das eine ist halt, ich habe meinen State weggekapselt, beziehungsweise ich bin quasi stateless, weil ich nur eine Funktion bin.
Und das andere ist, ich bin ein Objekt und ich habe Funktionen, die du aufrufen kannst, aber ich habe noch diesen State an mir draußen rankleben und auf mich können eventuell andere Leute Referenzen haben.
Und ich habe vielleicht noch tonnenweise Getter Setter auf meine Member,
die dann Leute beeinflussen können,
die alle den Ausgang meiner Methodenaufrufe beeinflussen können.
Wie stellt sich sowas eigentlich,
oder wie macht man sowas dann in funktionalen Programmiersprachen?
Wie macht man sowas in Haskell?
Da gibt es dann irgendeine Art von Objekten in Haskell oder in Idris?
Nein, es gibt wirklich nur sozusagen Datenstrukturen,
die du halt immer mitschleppen musst sozusagen.
Also deshalb musst du halt irgendwie bei funktionaler Programmierung, musst du häufig irgendwie ganz genau vorher irgendwie nachdenken, wie sollen eigentlich meine Typen aussehen, wie strukturiere ich das Ganze, dass ich nicht irgendwie 50 Eingabe-Werte in meine Funktion habe, sondern irgendwie ganz häufig irgendwie kommt so dieses wiederkehrende Pattern, dass man irgendwie den ganzen State von einem Modul, würde ich sagen, von einem abgeschlossenen Teil irgendwie,
der Software, dass man den
in einem einzigen
Datenwert drin hat,
dass du da so eine verschachtelte Struktur
drin hast. Das
findet sich zum Beispiel
bei React
im JavaScript-Umfeld.
Das kommt ja irgendwie von Elm, was ja auch
eine funktionale Sprache ist, eine pure
funktionale Sprache zur Abwechslung.
Da ist das zum Beispiel so.
Da hast du halt so ein
Objekt, wo du all deinen
State von einer
bestimmten Pipelines drin hast.
Von einer UI-Komponente, die einen State hat.
Ja, da iterierst du immer wieder
darüber. Oder
ein zweites Beispiel ist hier so
Erlang und Elixier.
Das sind
auch keine puren Sprachen.
Du kannst jederzeit irgendwie I.O. machen.
Du kannst jederzeit
irgendwie Netzwerksachen
machen, aber bei State,
der ist gekapselt in so einem
Aktor. So ein Aktor ist ja wie
so eine Art Thread, so ein ganz
gewichtiger Zweit, wo man irgendwie 10.000
von Starten kann, ohne dass es irgendwie
Probleme bringt.
Und da hast du halt immer
in so einem Aktor, hast du halt irgendwie
ein Objekt oder mehrere Objekte,
über die du iterierst.
Und da hast du halt eine
Funktion, die das macht. Die kriegt halt
dieses Objekt rein, dann machst du irgendwas damit
und gibst das veränderte
Objekt wieder zurück und
darüber loopst du halt sozusagen.
Und da musst du halt vorher
Gedanken machen, was jetzt von meinem Aktor
irgendwie von meinem Modul oder von meiner Pipeline,
was sind so die
wichtigen Sachen, die sich irgendwie verändern sollen
und die packst du halt dann irgendwie in so ein
Ding rein. Und in
ESCAP zum Beispiel hast du irgendwie die Stake-Monade,
die funktioniert
genauso, dass du halt irgendwie eine
Sache anheften kannst an
die Funktionen und diese Monade
schleppt die halt mit und du musst das nicht immer
als Parameter der Funktionen
mitschleifen, sondern du kannst dann
halt in der Funktion kannst du irgendwie aufrufen,
hier get, also kriege den Wert,
den ich da in meinem State habe
und
dann kannst du irgendwie
die Parameter für irgendwie wirkliche Parameter
verwenden und nicht über das, worüber du
die ganze Zeit integrierst. Wenn man das dann noch
this oder self nennt,
dann hat man schon fast wieder so ein bisschen ein Konzept
von Objekteorientierung, oder?
Ja, aber mit dem
absoluten Unterschied, dass dir nicht
irgendwie jemand währenddessen
reingrätschen kann.
das dein State
und nur du kannst den verwenden und du gibst
am Anfang irgendwas rein und
auch wenn diese Funktion sich immer wieder selbst
aufruft und den State
dabei die ganze Zeit verändert,
kann nicht irgendwo von irgendjemand
so, keine Ahnung,
kilometerweit entfernt in dieser Software
irgendwie ein anderes Modul, was zufällig
irgendwie eine Referenz darauf hat,
plötzlich den State da verändern,
sondern das dein State und über den
loopst du irgendwie drüber
Und den veränderst du ihn halt.
Aber jetzt erklären wir endlich mal das mit dieser IOMonade auf.
Genau, richtig.
Also das Wichtigste, was man verstehen muss,
ist, dass die IOMonade mit IOM gar nichts zu tun hat.
Also die IOMonade sorgt dafür,
dass die monadischen Funktionen, die man miteinander verbindet,
was alles solche Funktionen sind,
die eben ein IOMonade hinterher rausgeben,
dass die sequenziell abgearbeitet werden.
Das heißt, die Ursächlichkeit, wieso du sowas möchtest,
ist eben, dass die Sprache lazy ist.
Und lazy bedeutet, dass bestimmte Teile, die du irgendwie hinschreibst in deinem Programm,
die werden eventuell gar nicht ausgeführt
oder die werden halt irgendwie in einer total verqueren Reihenfolge ausgeführt.
Also man kann sich irgendwie so ein Haskell-Programm zum Beispiel, kann man sich im Endeffekt, wenn man die ganzen Funktionen inlinen würde, kann man sich vorstellen als eine riesige Formel sozusagen.
Das kann man sich vielleicht bei so einem Lisp-Dialekt, kann man sich das noch besser vorstellen oder so einem Lambda-Kalkül-ähnlichen Ding mit so ganz vielen Klammern.
dass im Endeffekt ein gesamtes Programm
kann halt eine riesige Formel sein,
irgendwie ein Rezept, was man abarbeitet.
Und da muss man aber gar nicht vorne anfangen,
sondern das ist halt wie in Mathe,
dass so irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt 1 plus 2 plus 5 rechne,
dann kann ich entweder mit 1 plus 2 anfangen
oder ich kann mit 2 plus 5 anfangen.
Man kann also mit drin auch wo anfangen,
was zusammenzufassen und zu vereinfachen.
Genau, richtig.
Also das ist tatsächlich, da sind wir bei dem dritten Punkt angekommen,
nämlich referenzielle Transparenz, nenne ich es jetzt mal.
Das war der zweite Punkt nochmal.
Das war der Punkt nochmal.
Habe ich dir irgendwas ausgelassen?
Das waren hier Immutable Data-Style.
Achso, gibt's nicht.
Das sind wir noch gar nicht.
Wobei, waren wir schon.
Haben wir schon mal so ein bisschen.
Genau.
Referenzielle Transparenz heißt, ein Ist-Gleich ist ein Ist-Gleich.
Kurz gesagt, also in anderen Programmiersprachen,
benutzt man ja ein ist gleich
als ein Zuordnungsoperator,
würde ich sagen. Also ich schreibe
etwas in eine Variable rein
und wenn ich jetzt aber in Haskell schreibe
a ist gleich 5, dann ist das
wirklich ein ist gleich und dann
ist entweder dieses a vorher schon definiert
und es entweder 5 oder nicht 5 und wenn es nicht 5
ist, dann crasht es irgendwie.
Oder es ist vorher noch nicht definiert und
dann wissen wir ab dem Zeitpunkt a ist 5.
Das heißt so eine Aussage wie x ist gleich x
plus 1 ist eigentlich nur ein Sensical.
Genau, richtig. Das kannst du in Haskell halt nicht schreiben.
Die Programmiersprachen waren alle so viel einfacher,
bevor wir die Zuweisung erfunden.
Ja, gleich ein paar Rater dafür
einfach genutzt.
Genau, und das ist halt genauso,
wenn man sich das vorstellt, wir haben so eine riesige
Formel, das ist unser Programm,
dann kann ich an allen Ecken und Enden, kann ich mal
anfangen irgendwie und Sachen vereinfachen
und Sachen ausführen. Und zum Beispiel,
wenn ich jetzt da ein
Programm habe, was erst irgendwie
aus einer Datei liest
und dann
auf diesem Wert irgendwas macht und es
in die Datei wieder reinschreibt,
dann könnte es halt in so einer
lazy Programmiersprache,
wenn es da eben, wenn das überhaupt erlaubt wäre,
sowas zu schreiben, könnte es halt passieren,
dass der zuerst versucht,
auf die Datei zu schreiben,
aber mit einem Wert, den er noch gar nicht
errechnet hat.
Und genau aus dem Grund brauchen wir
die IOMonade. Die bringt nämlich
eine Reihenfolge rein.
Das heißt, wenn ich in der
IOMonade jetzt zum Beispiel drei solcher
monadischen Funktionen
hintereinander
verkette.
Dann wird die erste zuerst ausgeführt,
die zweite als zweites und die dritte als drittes.
Und das
macht man im Endeffekt sozusagen
mit so einer Monade,
weil
man da sozusagen so ein bisschen
wie bei dieser State-Monade,
bei der State-Monade
schleppt man sozusagen in seiner
Kette immer
sein State-Objekt mit und
so eine IOMonade
kann man sich vorstellen, dass man
so ein
die Außenwelt mit sich mitschleppt.
So ein verstecktes Bogus-Objekt sozusagen
mitschleppt, was aber immer
übergeben muss,
übergeben werden muss, von
einem zum nächsten sozusagen,
um sicherzustellen,
dass man das nacheinander
macht sozusagen. Das heißt, ich kann mir diese IOMonade nehmen,
dann kann ich da irgendwie eine Detail erzeugen, dann kann ich da
fünf Zellen reinschreiben, dann kann ich da
was anderes machen, dann kann ich
fünf Zeilen wieder rauslöschen und dann
mache ich die Datei wieder zu und im Endeffekt
wird das nach dem Kompilieren
hat es nie stattgefunden,
weil im Endeffekt dieses State
sich vereinfachen lässt
und die Operationen betragen.
Genau, also der Punkt ist,
es gibt halt in Haskell einen Unterschied
zwischen
Evaluierung und
das fällt mir gerade nicht ein.
Auf jeden Fall kannst du sozusagen
die normale Vereinfachung auf
purem Code, die
funktioniert referenziell
transparent.
Und
diese IOMonade,
das im Endeffekt sozusagen
kommt dann ein Objekt
raus hinten aus
deinem Programm, wo diese ganzen
Kette noch irgendwie
verschachtelt ist.
Und das ist alles pur
geschehen. Also du hast sozusagen
eine Art Rezept erzeugt,
was besagt, mach erst das,
dann das, dann das, dann das.
Und dann nimmt die Haskell-Runtime,
nimmt das und gibt da dieses Bogus-Objekt am Anfang rein
und dann führt es diese Kette aus sozusagen.
Und in dieser Kette sind aber jetzt ganz normale Seiteneffekte mit drin,
die aber zum einen nicht so viel Schaden anrichten können,
weil wir halt irgendwie nicht veränderbare Datenstrukturen und sowas haben.
Und zum anderen kann ich halt klar unterscheiden zwischen,
welche Teile von meinem Programm sind es pure Teile und welche sind I.O.-Teile.
Aber diese I.O.-Monade ist im Endeffekt wirklich nur irgendwie,
ich speichere da drin eine Abfolge von Aufrufen von solchen I.O.-Funktionen,
also sowas wie, liest was aus einer Datei, schreibt was aufs Netzwerk und so weiter und so fort,
wie die dann sozusagen von
irgendwie der magischen
Haskell-Runtime dann ausgeführt werden.
Okay.
Das
leuchtet auch ein.
Genau, und der dritte Punkt,
den hatten wir, glaube ich, irgendwie jetzt schon so ein bisschen.
Kannst du die drei Punkte nochmal wiederholen?
Das ist das Purheit.
Das heißt, im Deutschen auch Purity
ist das irgendwie
komisch, Purheit kann man nicht
Reinheit von Funktionen sagen.
Das klingt beides irgendwie perfekt.
Okay, Reinhard, kannst du ja ziemlich
richtig sagen im Deutschen. Ziemlich gutes Buch
jetzt gerade gelesen von Jonathan
Fentzen. Das heißt Purity
auf Englisch und
das heißt auf Deutsch ein Unschuld, aber ich glaube,
das lässt sich nicht übertragen.
Unschuldiges Programmieren. Ich glaube,
wir haben gerade ein Sendungstuhl gefunden.
Genau, also es war Purheit.
Sowas, was
Haskell macht und AIM macht und
ansonsten aber fast nichts. Also
wie noch so ein paar abgefahrene Sprachen
eben wie Idris zum Beispiel.
Und
das war
referenzielle Transparenz.
Sachen, die mit einem
istgleich definiert sind, egal ob das jetzt
irgendwie Variable und
Wert ist oder irgendwie
Funktionsnamen und Funktionsdefinitionen,
die kann ich in beide
Richtungen ersetzen. Also wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel
sage, f von
x istgleich und dann
meine Funktionsimplementierung habe,
dann ist das auch wirklich ein istgleich.
Das heißt, wenn ich dieses F von irgendwas irgendwo stehen habe,
dann kann ich das eins zu eins ersetzen
oder auch im Vorhinein inline, wenn man das möchte,
mit der Implementierung.
Geht aber auch andersrum.
Das ist dann cool, wenn man irgendwie über Programmcode
irgendwie Aussagen machen möchte.
Das heißt, wenn ich diesen Funktionsrumpf irgendwo habe,
kann ich ohne Probleme da auch wieder den Funktionsausruf draus basteln,
wenn ich da Bock zu habe.
Das heißt, das geht in beide Richtungen.
ist gleich sozusagen.
Purheit, referenzielle
Transparenz und
Immutable Data Structures.
Ich denke, das ist das, was die meisten
funktionalen Sprachen irgendwie
haben, ist, dass wenn ich jetzt irgendwie
eine Liste habe und
die irgendwie verändere,
irgendwie da ein Objekt rausgehe.
Machst halt eher Copy-on-Write, anstatt dass du das
Objekt selber modifizierst. Genau.
Also dann habe ich halt hinterher
sozusagen gedacht, eine neue Liste,
wo dieses Element halt fehlt.
und das ist halt ziemlich cool,
weil da kann ich mir
ganz sicher sein, wenn ich dann eine neue Liste
habe, dass nicht jemand
irgendwie, oder wenn jemand dann
die alte Liste irgendwie verändert, dann ist mir das
total egal, weil ich ja eine neue Liste
habe und die habe nur ich und die kann
nur ich benutzen.
Ich habe mal noch einen Punkt 4 hinzugefügt,
Functions as First Class Types,
also für mich eigentlich dachte ich auch noch
so ein essentielles Feature
von den meisten funktionellen Sprachen.
higher-kinded,
higher-order-functionen.
Dass du halt mit Funktionen machen kannst, was du auch mit anderen Werten machst,
dass du die umherreichen kannst.
Das macht ja fast jede Sprache heutzutage.
Genau. Also ich würde es, glaube ich,
eher First-Class-Functions
nennen, weil es nämlich auch First-Class-Types
gibt.
Achso, okay.
Das gibt es so eine niedere,
oder kann man auch jetzt sagen.
Genau.
Also First-Class-Functions ist sozusagen,
ich kann Funktionen
rumreichen wie Werte.
Also ich kann zum Beispiel einer Funktion, kann ich eine Funktion übergeben oder ich kann auch von der Funktion eine Funktion zurückbekommen.
Und so, keine Ahnung, so Map hat wahrscheinlich jeder schon mal irgendwie gehört von.
Ich kann sagen, ich mappe auf irgendeinem Container an der Liste zum Beispiel.
Und wenn da einfach eine Funktion, die ich bekomme, als Parameter auf jedem Element dieser Containerstruktur irgendwie an.
Das ist ja halt das, was
man sich mal wieder
zur Gemüte führen muss. Eigentlich ist Functional Programming gar nicht so
abgefahren, weil viele von den Features, die du gerade
aufzählst, sind halt, ist jetzt auf
referenzielle Transparenz
in sehr vielen modernen
Sprachen bereits angekommen.
Was ja schon synchronisiert.
Ja gut, okay, jetzt ist fast eine Stunde rum. Jetzt haben wir die Grundlagen
gelegt so ein bisschen.
Dann können wir doch mal
auf ein bisschen spannendere Themen eingehen. Also zum
einen, wir unterscheiden
zwei Sorten TDD.
Das eine heißt
Test-Driven Development
und das andere ist ein Thema,
was du vorhin auch schon mal erwähnt hast.
Ich weiß gerade gar nicht mehr, ob wir es in der Pre-Show hatten
oder ob wir es schon auf Band haben.
Type-Driven Development.
Das könnten wir
doch mal ganz kurz erklären, oder?
Ja, also
Test-Driven Development sagt einem
vielleicht irgendwie noch was. Also ich
schreibe sozusagen, bevor ich irgendwie eine Komponente
schreibe, schreibe ich die Tests dafür.
Genau. Ich beschreibe erst mal das
Runtime-Verhalten von etwas.
Wenn ich das reingebe, möchte ich, dass das
rauskommt, dann fülle ich das hinterher aus.
Genau. Und von der Idee her
ist das was ganz Ähnliches wie
Type-Driven-Development, weil man sich
vorher überlegt, wie soll
denn eigentlich das, was ich jetzt
programmiere, das kann irgendwie eine Funktion zum Beispiel
sein oder ein ganzes Software-Modul,
wie soll sich das denn eigentlich
verhalten?
Bei Type-Driven-Development genauso.
So
Typsysteme
können ja unterschiedlich stark sein
und diese
Stärke ist halt irgendwie auch so
eine super undefinierte
Das ist auch das für so Begriff,
wo Leute Angst vorkriegen. Was ist denn ein starkes
Typ-System? Genau, richtig.
So ein bisschen
kann man es glaube ich nur erfühlen, was ein
starkes Typ-System ist.
Sehr esoterisch.
Fühle die Stärke des Typ-Systems.
Ich denke, an dem einen Ende der Fahnenstange ist halt sowas wie JavaScript.
Es geht halt immer darum, kann ich jetzt sozusagen Sachen miteinander verbinden,
irgendwie mit Funktionen oder sowas, die gar nicht den Typ haben, den ich erwarte,
oder kann ich das nicht?
Also zum Beispiel in JavaScript dieses ist gleich, ist gleich.
Oh ja.
Das ist ja absolut nicht
typsicher sozusagen.
Das ist so untypsicher,
dass du halt irgendwie
keine Ahnung,
eine
Dictionary mit
einer Liste irgendwie
vergleichen kannst und manchmal kommt ja raus
und manchmal nein und das hat
noch nicht mal irgendwie so
Einfolge ist wichtig.
Es hat weder
Assoziativität noch
Kommutativität, also
Warten, zwei aufeinander vor wen aufrufen,
gleiches Verhalten, also zumindest das kann man schon mal
voraussetzen.
Ich hätte aber tatsächlich neulich auf Arbeit
mit einem Kollegen einen kurzen Disput
gemeint, der hat ja
er ist JavaScript-Entwickler und ist so ein bisschen
sehr kritisch, zu Recht, gegenüber
Object-Oriented Programming und deswegen
ist der Code, er beinhaltet
auch keinerlei wirkliche Klassen, die wir da in der Hand
haben, dann erzähle ich ihm immer
was von TypeScript und
er sagt, ja, aber das ist ja,
das hat ja auch das Klassen-Keyword mit eingeführt
das kommt ja über das JavaScript. Ja, aber wenn du da
Typen ranschreibst, das ist nicht gut.
Die Typen hat die Sprache schon. Eigentlich ist
das JavaScript getypt.
Ich habe den Typen Funktion,
ich habe den Typen Objekt, ich habe den Typen String
und was es dynamisch macht,
ist, dass es eine Variable zur Laufzeit
unterschiedliche Typen annehmen kann.
Ich kann da mal was anderes reinschreiben.
Das ist das, was es dann
frickelig macht, wenn du das nicht anständig einhältst.
Vielleicht kurz eine Anekdote
von
schwacher Typisierung
kurz erzählen, das ist nämlich
letzte Woche erst passiert. Und zwar kam
meine Nachbarin von unten hoch
und meinte, ja wir...
So gegen klassische Programmiersprache.
Sehr gespannt, was jetzt kommt.
Genau, die meinte, ja hier
also wir machen gerade
so eine Programmieraufgabe,
das ist irgendwie Bauingenieure
und die haben
vorher so ein bisschen Java gemacht
und das war schon halt
schwer für die, weil es halt gar nicht so richtig
eingeführt wurde und plötzlich sollten sie irgendwelche Programme
schreiben damit. Und jetzt
machen sie irgendwie so ein Mathe-Zeug und
müssen Vortran machen.
Richtig super cool.
Das habe ich halt auch noch nie benutzt.
Top aktuell.
Die meinten halt, naja,
wir haben hier eigentlich eine relativ simple
Formel, irgendwie mathematische Formel,
die wollen wir anwenden.
Und da geben wir irgendwie
Parameter rein
kommt ein super kleiner Wert raus.
Das müsste eigentlich ein ziemlich großer Wert sein.
Also kam irgendwie so ein Wert irgendwie im
0,000
Wertebereich so raus
ungefähr. Und
echt irgendwie
lange gebraucht, um zu checken, was da
eigentlich falsch war. Also ich habe
dann diese Formel, die halt in der
Funktion einfach drin war irgendwie, war
so f von und dann drei Parameter
und mit diesen drei Parametern haben
sie noch irgendwelche Vektoren, die da definiert waren,
haben sie irgendwie verbunden.
und dann habe ich die ja immer weiter reduziert
und es war immer falsch und dann habe ich einfach mal
f von
abc ist gleich a
eingegeben und auch
das stimmte nicht.
Habe ich hinterher das a ausgegeben und zwar immer noch was kleines.
Und dann hat sich herausgestellt,
dass das halt irgendwie definiert war
als real, also als Double
Wert, dieses a, b
und c und was wir
reingegeben haben, war der Wert 1.
Und der Wert
1 ist in Fortran ein Int,
was man
nicht erkennen kann, wenn man es nicht weiß.
Dann haben wir 1.0
hingeschrieben und plötzlich ging es.
Das ist ein Beispiel
für schwache
Typisierung,
weil wir sogar schon hingeschrieben haben,
dass diese Funktion
einen Double-Wert
entgegennimmt,
aber der sozusagen das automatisch
umgewandelt hat.
Das hat auch gepostet.
Zeichen für schwache Typisierung,
wenn Sachen automatisch umgewandelt
werden, in der Hoffnung, dass
der Programmierer das schon gemeint hat.
In Haskell kannst du halt wirklich
nur die Sachen dann in so eine Funktion
reingeben, die da genau dastehen.
Und wenn da jetzt irgendwie
ein Int
drin ist und ein Integer
wird reingegeben, also ein Int ist sozusagen
das Maschinenint,
das hat halt zum Beispiel
64-Bit-Länge oder sowas,
und ein Integer ist sozusagen ein
unendliches Int.
Warte mal kurz, was? Ich höre dich fast gar nicht auf dem...
Du hörst mich fast gar nicht?
Jetzt besser, ja.
Dann muss ich halt vorher das
explizit umwandeln
ineinander, was ja sein könnte, dass mein Integer
riesig ist und gar nicht in dieses
64-Bit-Int reinpasst.
Und irgendwie in der schwachen
Sprache würde der es halt versuchen und dann
wahrscheinlich irgendwie in Overflow machen
oder sowas. Und das...
Undefined Behavior. Genau.
Das ist eine stark typisierte Sprache.
Fängt sowas halt schon beim Kompilieren ab und sagt hier,
mein Freund, so geht es nicht.
Das Problem rett man in sehr vielen Sprachen rein.
Ich hatte quasi genau dieselbe Issue.
Ich habe halt jetzt, glaube ich, zum vierten Jahr in Folge
so ein Modul Info 2 für Maschinenbauer,
wo die so ein bisschen Informatik beigebracht bekommen.
Und die sollen da in C-Sharp was bauen.
Die Aufgabe war irgendwie ein Dreieck definiert,
zeichnen auf so einer Zeichenfläche.
Und die sollten da den Schwerpunkt berechnen.
Und dafür musstest du den Durchschnitt der X-Koordinaten bilden,
also die X-Koordinaten der Summe aufaddieren.
von den Punkten und das durch Dreiteil.
Und in der Formel, die halt auf dem Übungsblatt
drauf stand, die abbilden, sondern stand mal ein Drittel.
Und das haben halt viele auch hingeschrieben, mal
eins durch drei. Und eins durch drei
war halt für sich scharfe Interdivision und dann mal
eins durch drei, was auf null
rechnen wird, ist dann die X-Grenade natürlich null.
Wieso geht das nicht?
Die machen einfach, was sind die falsch?
Ah, klar.
Das sieht man natürlich überhaupt nicht, weil die gerade
falsch läuft, aber klar. Das ist die Problematik,
die hat man, wenn das einfach so
passiert.
Das passiert in jeder Sprache fast.
Der muss eigentlich aufpassen, aber in Haskell eben nicht.
Also in Haskell kannst du nur
Doubles zum Beispiel
dividieren oder irgendwie
entsprechende Werte.
Ja, was könnte man auch ein Stringen mit einer Zahl?
Und solange der mit einer Zahl
anfängt, ist es auch übersetzbar in der Zahl.
Ja, krass.
Das ist total übel.
Es gibt halt echt viele krasse
Fehlerquellen.
Achso, erzähl weiter.
Komm, jetzt erzähl doch die eine.
Was du und Sascha letztens meintest,
in JavaScript kannst du ja auch noch ein Number wieder zu einer Zahl
machen, indem du das in die, was war die
Funktion, in den Integer Initializer,
der irgendwie eine Basis noch mitnimmt und wenn du deine
Basis über 24 nimmst, dann
würden ja auch deine An wieder zu einer Zahl.
Nee, es gibt
PassInt und da gibt es eine
Basis an und
da sind not a Number
nee, warte mal,
ich kriege gerade nicht mehr zusammen,
auf irgendeinem Punkt war es sinnlos und wenn du dann
wieder eine bestimmte Größe an Basis angibst,
Ab 24 wurde ein NIN auch in dem
Pass-In zu einer Zahl. Achso, genau.
Den String
hat es als
Nun geparst, seitdem die Basis war größer als
24. Da frage ich mich,
die Anekdote, warum man
das implementiert hat und wie das dazu gekommen ist,
würde mich schon mal sehr interessieren.
Aber gut, okay. Also jetzt
haben wir festgestellt, dass Haskell eine super
tolle Programmiersprache ist. Genau, stimmt. Jetzt sind wir
ein bisschen abgeschiffen.
Wir waren bei Type-Driven-Development.
Wir waren bei Typ-Systemen und beim Unteren
der Fahnenstange.
Ich würde persönlich
häufig Typ-Systeme und
Functional Programming in einen Hut
werfen, aber eigentlich gibt es
funktionale Programmiersprachen,
die kein
strenges Typ-System haben.
Ja, klar. Closure zum Beispiel, oder?
Closure. Und Elixir
auch, ne? Erlang.
Also es gibt schon
einige.
Die haben aber dann, das sind meistens Sprachen, die sehr opinionated sind, würde ich sagen.
Also bei denen halt die gesamte Standard-Library und sowas irgendwie einem bestimmten Konzept folgt,
was es nicht so schlimm macht, würde ich sagen, dass man keine Typen hat.
Aber auch in beiden Sprachen gibt es Bestrebungen, dass da irgendwie als Erweiterung Typen erlaubt sind sozusagen.
Viele Leute wünschen sich das halt irgendwie auch und das kann natürlich auch Vor- und Nachteile haben, aber wenn man halt irgendwie korrekten Code schreiben möchte und sich irgendwie, das ist halt irgendwie auch eine Stütze.
Und bei Stütze sind wir wieder angekommen bei Type-Driven-Development.
Ah, genau.
Das ist die Idee, dass ich vorher meine Typen schreibe.
Und das funktioniert halt nur, wenn ich ein so starkes Typ-System habe,
dass ich wirklich meine Funktion, würde ich sagen, beschreiben kann, was sie macht.
Also wenn ich so Sachen sagen kann wie meine Append-Funktion, also wenn ich zwei Listen zusammenfüge sozusagen, die hat hinterher die Länge von dem ersten plus die Länge von dem zweiten oder sowas.
Oder wenn ich noch stärker in dem Typsystem ausdrücken kann, meine Sortierfunktion, die sortiert auch eine Liste. Also da kommt hinterher, wenn es das sortiert hat, kommt eine Liste von aufsteigenden Elementen raus.
So was kann man in manchen Typsystemen ausdrücken.
Genau, richtig. Du meintest eben, mit Haskell sind wir am Ende der Fahnenstange, das stimmt nicht. Also auch Haskell hat, würde ich sagen, in den Forschungskreisen ein noch relativ schwaches Typsystem.
Es gibt immer Leute, die noch was härteres machen.
Also du kannst halt irgendwie
in Haskell zum Beispiel, wenn du
5 durch 0 teilst, kriegst du eine
Exception.
Das
wird dir nicht zur Compile-Zeit
verboten, dass du irgendwelchen Code
schreibst, der irgendwie crashen kann
sozusagen. Das geht immer
noch sozusagen. Also du kannst, du kommst
sehr selten, würde ich sagen, in diese Bedrohle.
Aber
das gibt es. Es gibt
Sachen, die kann Haskell nicht
zur Compile-Zeit
dir sagen.
Zum Beispiel, dass in einer Variable
keine Null drin steckt.
Das kannst du zwar irgendwie modellieren,
indem du einen neuen Integer-Typ
machst oder sowas.
Aber per se, wenn du jetzt einen
normalen Standard-Int nimmst, dann
kann der halt Null sein.
Und wenn du dann durch diese Variable teilst,
dann gibt es eine Exception und
das liegt erst um die Ohren.
Also das heißt, da ist Haskell halt eben nicht perfekt getypt sozusagen.
Und da gibt es halt Ansätze, wie man das verändern kann.
Und ein Ansatz ist eben das, was Idris macht.
Das nennt sich Dependent Types.
Und Dependent Types sind die Idee, dass ich, also normalerweise,
in den meisten Sprachen kann ich ja mittlerweile einen Typen mit einem Typen parametrisieren.
Also ich kann sagen, das ist ein List von Int.
Also dann habe ich den List-Typ parametrisiert mit Int.
Das heißt manchmal Templates oder Generics oder wie auch immer.
Oder Polymorphie.
Und in so einer Dependently-Type-Sprache
habe ich ein Typsystem, wo ich meinen Typen auch mit normalen Werten parametrisieren kann.
Also ich kann zum Beispiel sagen, das ist eine Liste vom Typ int mit der Länge 15.
Und dann kann der Wert von diesem Typ wirklich auch nur eine Liste sein, wo ints drin sind und der genau die Länge 15 hat.
Und damit kann ich halt irgendwie dann, also das Hello World der Dependent Types ist,
dass ich irgendwie eben so eine Append-Funktion habe und sage,
ich kriege eine Liste von Länge m rein und eine Liste von Länge n rein.
Und was rauskommt, ist eine Liste von Länge m plus n.
Und dann kann ich halt, wenn ich dann irgendwas implementiere,
wo ich, keine Ahnung, die ganzen Werte zusammen in eine Liste mache
und noch einen weiteren Wert dran schreibe,
dann kann der Compiler das hinterher checken und sagen,
hier, dass
leider
dein Typ, der da rauskommt, ist Liste
von Länge m plus n
plus 1. Aber das ist jetzt
ja noch, du redest gerade von
Dependent Types
und das ist jetzt, wenn man das
mit diesen Beispielen, das sind auch die Beispiele, die du meistens hörst,
ich habe eine Liste vom Typ von der Länge
n und ich habe eine Liste von
Länge m und wenn ich die addiere,
dann habe ich eine Liste von der gemeinsamen
Länge, das ist jetzt triviale Arithmetik,
das kann man im Compiler mal noch schnell hinschreiben,
beziehungsweise das kann man auch relativ gut nachvollziehen,
aber was sind denn noch andere
Anwendungsfälle von sowas?
Genau, also
das Beispiel, was ich ja gerade schon
genannt habe,
ist, dass ich zum Beispiel irgendwie,
wenn ich so Sortieralgorithmen umsetze,
dann kann ich halt
in den Typ schreiben, dass hinterher
eine sortierte
Liste auch rauskommt sozusagen.
Und das ist ja schon
irgendwie so ein bisschen Magie sozusagen,
würde ich sagen.
Du machst halt irgendwas in der Implementierung,
die kann auch total unterschiedlich sein,
das kann Merge Sort sein oder irgendwie Bubble Sort,
Quick Sort, wie auch immer.
Und du kannst halt in den Ausgabetyp,
das, was hinterher rauskommt, kannst du schreiben,
das ist eine sortierte Liste.
Und das funktioniert so,
dass du in deinen Typen
arbiträr zum einen logische Verbindungen verwenden kannst,
wie auch Funktionen.
Also du hast dann sozusagen Funktionen auf Typ-Level.
Teilweise kannst du Funktionen, also kommt auf die Sprache dran,
in Idris geht das, kannst du einfach Funktionen,
die du in dem normalen Programm-Level, in dem Typ-Level definiert hast,
kannst du eins zu eins übernehmen in die Typ-Welt
und kannst da halt sagen, na gut, ich habe hier einen Ausgabewert x
und sortiert x
muss wahr sein.
Das ist dann irgendwie eine Kunstfunktion oder
sowas sein.
Genau, also das ist dann im Endeffekt
ist das irgendwie eine rekursive
Funktion, die dann halt irgendwie
diesen
Typ durchgeht sozusagen und
guckt, ob
der
erste Wert da da drin ist, kleiner ist
als der zweite Welt kleiner ist und so weiter und so fort.
Und
in vielen Fällen kann das dann der Compiler oder der Typechecker, der da drin ist,
kann der das auch auflösen.
Also selbst in solchen Fällen.
Das gange jetzt so, als ob das noch eine Runtime-Komponente hat.
Hat es tatsächlich nicht. Das ist das Geile daran.
Du kannst tatsächlich beides haben.
du kannst, bei Idris hast du Typen, die bei Runtime erst erstellt werden.
Also du hast First Level Types, das heißt, du kannst einen Typen an eine Funktion übergeben
oder du kannst auch eine Funktion an einen Typen zurückgeben lassen.
Du kannst irgendwelche Typen errechnen, wenn du willst.
Das sind auf Typ Level irgendwie Funktionen, die du machst.
Aber die Beispiele, die ich jetzt bisher genannt habe,
die funktionieren alle zur Compile Time.
Also der kann halt sozusagen deine Implementierung
und den Typ, den du hast, kann er so miteinander verbinden,
dass er hinterher sagen kann, okay, dieser Code wird tatsächlich immer
diese logischen Eigenschaften, die ich da dran geschrieben habe,
mit dir haben.
Bei Idris ist es halt häufig so, dass du da an die Grenzen stößt, was der automatisch kann.
Und dass du dann manuell irgendwelche Beweisobjekte mitliefern musst.
Und das ist dann der Punkt, an dem das auch nicht mehr allgemeingültig einsetzbar ist, denke ich, dieses Ding.
Weil es einfach so für den Normalprogrammierer
zu kompliziert ist, da irgendwie so ein
Beweis irgendwo als Programmmeter mitzuliefern
und dann erst kann die Funktion das machen, was sie eigentlich soll.
Das ist ziemlich cool.
Das ist aber eine ganz andere Ebene, auf der du dann Probleme lösen musst.
Genau, aber das ist natürlich richtig cool, weil du ein
ganz enges Korsett um deine Implementierung
machen kannst und die Implementierung
kann halt wirklich hinterher nur das.
Und da sind wir halt auch schon ganz tief in so formalen Methoden drin, würde ich sagen.
Das ist halt die Idee, dass man Eigenschaften beweisen kann auf Programmen.
Und da gibt es halt irgendwie so Sachen wie COQ.
Da hast du halt irgendwie so eine sehr strenge, funktionale Sprache hast du da drin.
Und dann ist das ein Theorembeweiser,
wo du irgendwie logische Verknüpfungen kannst du irgendwie anlegen
und so Invarianten kannst du halt irgendwie,
okay, hier diese Funktion nimmt irgendwie ein Passwort entgegen
und gibt das aber niemals irgendwo an irgendeinem anderen Teil der Software raus.
Das kann man dann auf dem Typsystem quasi aufnehmen.
Und dann kannst du nur eine Implementierung hinschreiben,
die das auch so macht.
Also das Idris in COG kannst du erstmal irgendwie dein Programm schreiben
und kannst dann hinterher diesen Beweis darüber führen.
Den machst du aber manuell.
Das sind so diese beiden Richtungen, würde ich sagen.
Das eine sind manuelle Beweise.
In Idris geht halt vieles automatisch, würde ich sagen.
Und irgendwann muss man halt manuell übernehmen.
Und in COG machst du halt manuelle Beweise auf dieser Sprache.
Okay, jetzt machst du ja mit COG und mit formalen Beweisen schon wieder ein ganz anderes Fass auf.
Ich wollte ja nochmal eigentlich zwischendurch noch eine kurze Zwischenfrage stellen.
Weil ein Konzept, was mir aus Sprachen, die sowas nicht haben, trotzdem noch bekannt ist, ist Policy-Based Programming.
Mengen. Und zwar,
dass du quasi
wie
ein bisschen, ist das die statische
Variante zu einem
Strategy Pattern, dass du
einen Typ hast, den du mit einem anderen Typen
parametrisierst und aufgrund
diesem Parameter kannst du dann
statische Dispatches machen und
dich unterschiedlich verhalten. Also
wir hatten einen Logger und der
hat
Logs weggeschickt zu einem Remote Service
und der hatte zwei Strategien
und die eine Strategie, diese Strategie kann man halt statisch mit in das Objekt reintun
und die gibt vor, ob der sofort was wegsendet oder erst das cached und dann wegsendet.
Damit kann man dann sagen, das Verhalten von diesem Objekt weiß ich statisch vorher schon,
aber das ist quasi nur eine ganz einfache Variante davon.
Genauso gibt es irgendwie andere Policies, die du auf Typebene mit angeben kannst.
Aber das, was du hier beschrieben hast, ist tatsächlich,
ich kann während
der Compile-Time nochmal Code
ausführen lassen, der verifiziert,
dass meine Liste auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise
sortiert ist.
Genau. Also alles Compile-Zeit.
Dieses Policy-Based
kenne ich tatsächlich gar nicht.
Das klingt eigentlich ganz spannend. Das ist wahrscheinlich
so eine Vorstufe dann irgendwie zu solchen
Sachen. Also es funktioniert in C++
dementsprechend. Es ist nicht so krass auf die Seite.
Mehr an.
C++ kommt ja irgendwie jetzt immer
gefahrenere Sachen rein.
Im C++20 gibt es diese Konzepts,
die ich noch nicht komplett verstanden habe,
aber auch da kann man
so Invarianten definieren.
Es gibt schon mal ein Gedei,
dass C++ irgendwie
in seiner Lebenszeit je gleiche andere
Funktionalitäten von allen anderen Sprachen
schlucken wird. Sonst ist es nicht C++.
Ja, aber
so ist es eigentlich noch gar nicht.
Also entweder es fällt in C++
direkt rein oder es landet in Boost.
Das kannst du ja über viele andere Sprachen
genauso sagen.
Wenn ich das mal gelesen habe, dass
Bjarne Sostrup vor langer Zeit
mal mit der Idee gespielt hat,
das Leerzeichen in C++
als Multiplikationsoperator zu überlegen,
dass du es wirklich sehr mathematisch hinschreiben kannst.
A, B ist halt A mal B, ganz klar.
Immerhin haben wir es auch Leerzeichen und nicht einfach
nur A, B ist gleich A mal B.
Dann müsste es aber auch ohne Leerzeichen funktionieren.
Aber das hat es zumindest
nicht in C++ geschafft.
Ich weiß eigentlich vor
anderthalb Jahren oder sowas,
bei den Lambda Days
in Polen,
in Krakau.
Das ist eine funktional
Programmiererkonferenz.
Und da war irgendwie
so einer,
einer,
der
relativ bekannt ist
in diesem funktionalen Umfeld.
Und der meinte,
wir versuchen ja gerade
C++ funktional zu kapern.
Also die haben es
irgendwie immerhin jetzt schon mal geschafft,
dass da irgendwie so
eine vergleichsweise gute
Implementierung von Lambda-Funktionen drin ist
und
ich habe mich jetzt mit diesen Konzepts noch nicht beschäftigt,
aber ich brauche so ein bisschen das Gefühl,
das kommt aus der Ecke.
Ich folge ein paar C++-Gurus auf Twitter
und die posten manchmal
so Konzept-Syntax-Beispiele,
wie das aussehen würde.
Ich habe mir eigentlich gedacht,
Konzepts sind eigentlich
fast so ein bisschen was wie
Trade-Bounce.
in anderen Sprachen, wo du sagen kannst,
ich habe zwar Generics, aber die müssen
von dieser
Typklasse sein auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise.
Aber wenn ich mir die Beispiele dann angucke,
denke ich mir, ich verstehe überhaupt nicht,
das liest es sich auch überhaupt nicht.
Leute, mach doch mal was, was sich
irgendwie lesen lässt.
Aber wenn du sagst, dass man damit auch
krassere Sachen ausdrücken kann.
Wie gesagt,
ich weiß es nicht und ich
möchte ja auch nichts Falsches
erzählen.
Ich hatte nur das Gefühl, dass es vielleicht aus der Ecke kommt.
Dafür haben wir ja in der nächsten Folge Jupp zu Gast.
Genau, der kann das dann eventuell erzählen.
Kann er sich schon mal vorbereiten.
Nee, aber
wir haben jetzt einen schönen
Bogen geschlagen und
wir haben jetzt also Typsysteme. Das hat mit
Functional Programme eigentlich
nicht wirklich was zu tun, weil es ein eigenes
Konzept ist und es gibt Typsysteme,
die sind nicht nur streng, sondern die haben auch noch
Dependent Types. Das heißt,
wenn ich eine Operation auf einem
Typen mache, kommt ein
Typ dabei raus, der vom
Ausgang dieser Operation abhängt, quasi.
Und das kann man statisch
evaluieren. Und das erlaubt einem
jetzt noch striktere oder noch genauere
Aussagen über das Verhalten von Code zu treffen.
Und dabei
das erlaubt einem
nun, statische
Analyse auf einem ganz anderen
Level zu machen, nämlich, dass ich mit einem logischen
Beweiser oder einem Solver
mein
wirklich hochlevelige,
logische Aussagen über meinen Code treffe.
Treffe ich das gerade richtig? Genau.
Ich würde es vielleicht nicht statische Analyse nennen,
weil ja statische Analyse eher so
Patterns erkennt, würde ich sagen, im Code
eher so ein
statischer Check,
ein Korsett, aus dem
die Implementierung
nicht rauskommt sozusagen.
Also ich kann
arbitrier logische
Verknüpfungen sozusagen in die
Typen reinschreiben, sowohl in die
Eingabeparameter von so einer Funktion zum Beispiel
als auch in den Ausgabeparameter.
Man kann halt sagen, zum Beispiel bei einer
geteilt durch Funktion kann ich
halt bei dem zweiten
Parameter kann ich halt dran schreiben,
darf nicht 0 sein.
Das ist ja auch ungleich 0.
Das ist ja auch eine logische Verknüpfung
sozusagen oder ein logischer
Wert.
Solche Sachen kann man halt machen
und da sind wir sozusagen
mitten in den formalen
Methoden angekommen, weil das sozusagen
eine Art und Weise ist, wie ich
Invarianten oder logische
Verknüpfungen auf meinem Programmcode beweisen kann.
Es gibt
mehrere unterschiedliche, würde ich sagen. Wir haben eben schon mal ganz kurz
COG angesprochen. Da ist es so, da schreibt man es nicht in die Typen rein.
Da schreibt man sozusagen, würde ich sagen, separat sein
Programm implementiert das in dieser funktionalen Sprache, die da drin ist,
Kalina heißt sie, und dann kann ich
unabhängig davon, kann ich halt irgendwie sagen, naja, hier irgendwie
wenn ich folgende Funktionen so und so benutze, dann ist das das gleiche wie
folgendes anderes. Also ich kann irgendwie logische
Verknüpfungen aufstellen, die aber nicht direkt an dem
Code dranhängen als ein Typ, sondern die
separat davon sind. Man kann
separat dazu einen manuellen Beweis
machen. Und das
Schöne daran, wenn man das
an dem Code dran macht,
als eine Typ-Annotation oder
eine
Annotation auch nur,
da ist halt,
dass man
direkt
sozusagen den Code eingrenzt,
dass man es direkt sieht, dass man
die
Typen, die man halt vorher
hat, dass man die nochmal
ein bisschen klarer denkt,
nicht nur das ist ein Int, sondern das ist vielleicht
ein Int, der
größer ist als 2 und kleiner
als 16 und durch 3 teilbar
sein muss.
Da gibt es
auch wieder unterschiedliche Varianten von, also da gibt es
halt diese Dependent Types, die halt
super mächtig sind, würde ich sagen.
Also mit denen kannst du irgendwie
alles, was irgendwie
mit
Logic ausdrückbar ist, also
konstruktive Logik, da müssen wir nicht reingehen,
kannst du
damit ausdrücken.
Und dann gibt es aber noch, ich würde
sagen, die Light-Variante
davon, die
versucht, mit einem
SMT-Solver Sachen
zu beweisen auf dem Code.
Also dann kannst du genauso
Annotationen finden
darüber.
Das wahrscheinlich
bekannteste Beispiel ist
Liquid Haskell.
Das sind
Annotationen
noch, soll vielleicht mal
in die Sprache reinkommen,
die du einfach sozusagen entweder statt der Typen
über deine Funktion schreiben kannst
oder zusätzlich zu den Typen.
Das Konzept nennt sich
Refinement Types. Das heißt, ich
habe da eigentlich tendenziell erstmal
die Typen stehen, die ich auch sonst hinschreiben würde.
In String kommt ein
was-wie-was-double raus oder sowas.
Und die kann ich aber verfeinern mit ebenfalls logischen Verknüpfungen,
aber nur einem Subset, würde ich sagen,
also man kann nur bestimmte Operationen verwenden da drin,
die dann automatisch checkbar sind mit einem SAP-T-Solver.
Das kann dann aber nicht checken, dass das zur Runtime
vielleicht doch was anderes macht,
weil es nicht in den Körper der Funktionen reincheckt oder wie?
Doch, doch, doch.
Das guckt sich genauso die Implementierung an
und versucht sozusagen im Vorhinein sicherzustellen
oder alles, was du da drin verwenden kannst,
ist sozusagen ein Subset von normaler Logik.
Und auch da kannst du sogenannte Measures definieren.
Das heißt, du kannst auch Funktionen,
die du im Wert im normalen Programmbereich definiert hast,
kannst du übernehmen da rein.
Aber es ist so stark eingeschränkt.
Also unter anderem, was diese Funktion angeht,
die dürfen zum Beispiel nur einen Parameter haben
und dieser Parameter muss halt irgendwie ein Typ sein,
zu dem sie irgendwie gehören.
Deshalb heißt es auch Measure.
Es ist irgendwie etwas, was zu einem Typen gehört.
Also zum Beispiel kannst du irgendwie
Size von einer Liste
das ist ein Measure,
für der zu dieser Liste gehört
sozusagen und wenn ich
den einfach importiere,
dann kann ich den halt
in diesen Annotationen verwenden.
Und da kommt man verdammt weit mit
und man muss
nichts per Hand machen.
Also nicht wie ein Idris, wo dann
so ein Insertion Sort
zum Beispiel, wenn ich mal gesehen habe, kann dann halt
irgendwie auch mal mehrere Seiten lang sein, wenn man da
ordentlich krass die Typen
einschränken möchte.
Dann möchtest du dann einen Editor mit Code-Folding haben.
Und das ist halt schon ziemlich
sexy, weil du das einfach dran schreiben kannst und
der sagt dir hinterher, ja, stimmt.
Und
ein ähnliches Konzept hat
F-Star.
F-Star ist von Microsoft Research.
Und das ist eine Sprache,
die entwickelt wurde,
um,
also das Projekt heißt
Everest.
und die wollen einen komplett
verifizierten Stack,
Netzwerk-Stack bauen
bis hin zu
HTTP 2.
Das
beinhaltet solche Sachen
wie
IP und
alles, was da dann nach oben
HTTP und so weiter und so fort,
TCP, alles
beinhaltet auf der anderen Seite
aber auch Kryptografie.
Also HTTP2 ist,
ich glaube, das nicht mehr optional
ist mit der Verschüssung.
Das ist per default HTTPS.
Genau.
So was war eigentlich das Beispiel, was der,
wie hieß er, der Entwickler von
Idris? Ah, Edwin Brady.
Ja, was er in dieser
Code-Podcast-Folge
glaube ich auch ganz gut beschrieben hat,
die packe ich mal noch in die Show Notes,
dass sich diese Dependent-Type und
Type-Driven-Development genau, also
besonders gut dafür eignet,
Protokolle zu implementieren,
weil man bereits statisch Aussagen
über das Verhalten des Protokolls machen kann
und quasi
die ganzen State Machines, die man
normalerweise hinschreiben würde,
man dann beim
Testen erst rausfindet, nehmen die wirklich
auch die richtigen Zustände ein,
dass man das bereits
komplett statisch ausdrücken kann
auf die Art und Weise.
Genau das,
du brauchst ja halt die Invarianten,
wenn du bereits so ein AFC
hast, wo solche Sachen
beschrieben sind,
wie es zu funktionieren hat, die brauchst du dann einfach
nur noch übersetzen, irgendwie logische Formeln
und kannst dir halt
checken auf sowas. Das macht man
ja häufig bei RFCs überhaupt nicht oder bei
anderen Spezifikationen, dass sich mal
einer hinschreibt und das mal beweist.
Aber ich glaube, wenn
es so Default-Verhalten wäre, dass
man von bestimmten Protokollen einfach
in so einer, zum Beispiel
in Idris eine Elementierung schreibt,
hat mir quasi den Beweis von dem Protokoll selbst
schon geliefert.
Das wäre witzig, wer dann rauskommt.
Das kann nicht funktionieren.
Ja, das ist ein krasse
nächster Schritt auf jeden Fall,
wenn man das so einfach durchziehen könnte.
Was da zu dem Thema interessant ist, ich war auf der
Bob-Conf vor
zwei Monaten vielleicht
und das
auch so ein bisschen formale Methoden,
Funktionalprogrammierung und so
und ein Talk
da ging es um den
TCP
AFC
und wie die Realität davon abweicht.
Das war ziemlich lustig,
weil nämlich, also die haben auch halt
so... Von TCP selbst.
Ja, genau. Also die haben auch
so ein Modell halt irgendwie am Anfang gemacht
und haben halt den AFC sich genommen
und haben halt mal irgendwie so
die State Machine aufgeschrieben.
Und das waren dann irgendwie, ich weiß nicht,
vielleicht 30, 40 States oder irgendwie sowas.
Möglicherweise weniger.
wahrscheinlich viel weniger, keine Ahnung
und
haben dann irgendwie mal angefangen und haben
so eine übliche Implementierung von TCP
genommen, irgendwie so in
Linux zum Beispiel
und haben irgendwie
vier, fünf Referenzsachen irgendwie hergenommen
und haben irgendwie schnell
gemerkt, die halten sich da gar nicht dran
beziehungsweise
diese States
sind schon noch irgendwie da, aber teilweise sind die
gar nicht relevant und
diese
Implementierungen haben dann super viele
zwischen States einfach, die
sich auch komplett anders verhalten oder
überhaupt nicht spezifiziert sind und
dann hat er hinterher nochmal so ein Slide gezeigt,
da meinte er, naja und das ist jetzt das,
was eigentlich so in der Realität TCP ist
und zwar in so, keine Ahnung,
Hunderte von States.
Ich wollte gerade sagen, es ist einfacher oder es ist komplizierter,
als was spezifiziert ist.
Es ist komplizierter. Ich glaube, das hängt
alles irgendwie so mit Praxissachen zusammen,
dass man dann irgendwie sagt,
wenn ich gerade in einem DDoS-Angriff
stecke und
der und der Server sich nicht so
und so verhält, dann mache ich das und das oder so
wahrscheinlich. Also sobald du
Routing-Regeln hast, irgendwo drin wird es wahrscheinlich
auch ganz toll. Möglicherweise, ja.
Er hat auch nicht so viel gesagt darüber, was
jetzt diese zusätzlichen States sind, aber die
lagen halt dann entweder
zwischen den eigentlichen States oder haben die halt irgendwie
ersetzt. Fände ich nur interessant.
Krass, Anekdote am Rand.
Genau, und
waren wir bei dem Projekt Everest stehen geblieben.
Und das ist halt schon ziemlich krass,
weil die halt dieses F-Style komplett,
also so ein bisschen wie diese Mozilla-Geschichte mit Rust,
dass die erstmal eine Programmiersprache gemacht haben,
um ihren Browser neu zu schreiben.
Und das Projekt Everest hat halt eine Programmiersprache geschrieben,
um diesen HTTP-2-Stack komplett zu schreiben und verifizieren.
Und die sind damit immerhin schon mal so weit, dass jetzt seit dem vorletzten Firefox sind die ersten verifizierten Kryptoprimitiven für ein TLS drin.
Aber jetzt in F-Star?
Genau, die sind in F-Star geschrieben und die wurden dann irgendwie exportiert.
Ich bin nicht ganz häufig so bei solchen Sprachen, dass du das dann irgendwie exportieren kannst in eine andere Sprache und dann halt übersetzen kannst.
Und zwar kompilierst du es zu CE oder sowas.
Und
das ist halt schon ziemlich geil, muss ich sagen.
Aber ist dann verifiziert, dass man die Krypto
nicht brechen kann oder ist es
verifiziert, dass die Versprechen
von der Krypto eingehalten werden?
Was heißt denn
verifizierte Krypto-Algorithmen?
Genau, also verifiziert
ist erstmal auch ein super schaumiger Begriff,
wie wir jetzt irgendwie möglicherweise schon sehen.
Verifiziert ist ja eigentlich, ich sage
vorher ist, es stürzt nicht ab
und dann tut es das halt auch nicht.
Ist ja auch verifiziert auf den Kursar.
Genau, es hängt halt davon ab, was so deine
Aussagen sind, die du verifiziert hast.
Um vielleicht
zu den Listen zurückzukommen,
wenn ich jetzt irgendwie so eine Sortierfunktion habe,
kann ich halt entweder
darauf
verifizieren, dass
die Liste hinterher genauso
lang ist. Das ist schon mal
eine coole Aussage, würde ich sagen,
die mir weiterhilft, aber
das ist jetzt noch nicht besonders tiefgreifend
ich kann aber auch sagen
ich verifiziere, dass in der
Liste hinterher die gleichen Elemente
sind wie in der Liste vorher
das ist dann eine Stufe weiter würde ich sagen
oder ich kann halt verifizieren
dass tatsächlich eine sortierte Liste rauskommt
und wie jetzt
die Invarianten da
bei diesen Kryptoprimitiven
aussehen, das weiß ich nicht genau
aber ich nehme
an, dass die
da bei diesem
Project Everest, bei diesen
Kryptoprimitiven,
schon sozusagen die mathematischen
Invarianten von
diesen Kryptoprimitiven genommen haben und die dann
bewiesen haben. Aber auf dem
Weg sicherlich auch so Sachen wie
das kann halt nicht
overflown oder sowas.
Nicht da irgendwelche Modulo
Sachen machen oder keine Ahnung.
Das hat Microsoft entwickelt?
Microsoft Research.
Aber in Firefox ist es drin.
Firefox sitzt drin, ja.
Ja klar, also ich meine, wenn du sowas machst,
hast du natürlich Interesse daran, dass es,
wenn du eine gute Krypto machst, dann hast du Interesse daran,
dass es jeder benutzt und dann gibst es halt
in den Standardbrowser-Implementierern
einfach schon mal hin, dass die es einfach
verwenden können. Was ist besser
als bewiesene Krypto?
Der Idealzustand. Das sind jetzt
halt die ersten Sachen, die da drin
sind, so ein bisschen wie die
ersten Rust-Sachen,
die jetzt in Firefox drin sind, aber es wird halt
Schritt für Schritt mehr werden, das
halt schon mal ganz cool, weil so ein Browser ja echt
auch eine riesige Angriffsfläche bietet
irgendwie für diverse Sachen.
Die größte, ja. Aber wo wir gerade bei
Rust sind.
Hendricks Herz schlägt
über. Du hattest mir
jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob du dich
daran erinnerst, aber wir hatten vor
einiger Zeit mal auf einer Party
ganz kurz darüber geredet,
dass du dich auch ein bisschen
da reingeguckt hast und gesagt hast,
ja Mensch, das mit den Lifetimes, das sind ja quasi
eigentlich
Kannst du das nochmal wiederholen? Kriegst du das noch zusammen?
Ja, das
Konzept
von
diesem Borrowing und sowas.
Genau.
Also es ist zumindest so, dass es ja auch
Immutable Data Structures gibt, dass Sachen
per default immutable sind.
Aber du hast auch gleichzeitig noch ein
wohl definiertes Konzept von wem
gehört eine Variable oder eine Ressource
und wer leitet sie sich aus.
Und wenn eine Variable
ausgeliehen ist, dann kann man statisch sagen,
dass die dann nicht mehr mutable sein darf, beziehungsweise wenn sie mutable ausgeliehen ist, dann darf sie auf der anderen Stelle auch nicht mehr mutable weiterverarbeitet werden.
Es können mehrere Leute Referenz drauf haben, aber nur einer darf es own und auch nur einer darf jeweils einen Mutable-Zugriff haben.
Und dadurch, dass es eine statische Aussage ist, die man bereits beim Kompilieren treffen kann, ist es ja quasi Teil des Typsystems, wenn man es so nimmt.
Ja, könnte man so sehen.
Mindestens Teil der Sprache, der Compile-Time-Checks.
Und ist das was, was man
zum Beispiel in Idris
mit Dependent Types ausdrücken könnte?
Ich glaube ja.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Es gibt aber
tatsächlich eine
Typerweiterung, zumindest gibt es
die bei Haskell, die sich halt
Linear Types nennt.
Linear Types sind eben
genau das. Nur, dass
man sie eben über die Typen definiert
und dass sie eben nicht wie ein Rust,
was ziemlich cool ist, omnipräsent
sind. Also du musst es
immer machen.
Da kannst du es halt sozusagen auf einer Funktion machen.
das gräbt sich dann so
rekursiv durch, dass wenn irgendwie jetzt
eine lineare Funktion
hast, dann darfst du da auch
nur lineare Dinge drin machen,
sozusagen.
Das heißt, es ist nicht wie eine Monade
quasi, die man um etwas drum rum
rappt und dann hat man eine Monade von diesem Typen,
sondern es ist
Genau, das ist sozusagen das genaue Gegenteil.
Bei so einer Monade ist es ja so,
du kannst die,
also zumindest die IO-Monade kannst du,
wenn du einmal da drin bist, kannst du sie nicht verlassen.
Du kannst nur Sachen, die nicht monadisch sind,
da drin ausführen oder aufrufen.
Das heißt, da ist sozusagen,
wenn man die Main-Funktion
irgendwie so als
den oberen Bereich vielleicht
sieht so visuell,
dann ist da erstmal so
eine Schicht, die ist irgendwie IO und dann
kann man so an
verschiedenen Enden gibt es dann eben
die
puren Ausläufer sozusagen
und bei diesen linearen Typen
ist es halt genau andersrum, wenn
ab irgendeinem
Punkt in diesem AppStract Syntax
Tree, wenn da was
als linear, also
diese Funktion als linear beschrieben ist,
dann ist sozusagen alles, was
da Subtree-mäßig
im AppSync-Syntax-Tree
ist, muss auch linear sein.
Genau, das heißt,
du kannst dann sozusagen in einem
definierten Umfeld kannst du
solche
Ownership-Sachen machen,
aber
das auch gerade erst am Anfang,
ich hab da auch noch nicht
wirklich mit rumgespielt
und das ist halt in Rust echt
cool, dass das halt
immer da ist. Was werden denn für
Beispiele in Haskell beschrieben, die man
mit linearen Typen...
Naja, ganz viele Sachen gehen halt
irgendwie so um Ressourcen, die du
halt dann irgendwie,
die du schließen musst zum Beispiel,
aber die du auch nur einmal schließen
darfst. Also so ein File Descriptor
zum Beispiel irgendwie kann,
wenn ich den
normalen Haskell benutze, kann
das halt passieren, dass ich versuche den zweimal
zu schließen und das
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht, was dann passiert, was ein Fehler ist
oder dann
einfach schon geschlossen ist.
So richtig cool ist das halt nicht.
Und da kannst du halt sagen,
ich mache das irgendwie linear hier
und dann
gibst du den nur einmal sozusagen
oder ich kann immer nur eine
Schreibreferenz darauf
haben
und kann den auch nicht irgendwie,
kann diese Schreibreferenz auch nicht duplizieren
und kann deshalb auch nur
an einer Stelle irgendwie sagen,
hier, ich schließe das wieder.
Genau, und
das habe ich jetzt aber noch
nicht viel angewandt gesehen, das ist wie gesagt auch relativ
neu und
das ist aber, finde ich spannend,
dass das halt irgendwie,
dass da die Rust-Leute ein
würde ich sagen
ziemlich
unbeflecktes Gebiet
der Typ-Theorie genommen haben,
was es irgendwie an
diversen Stellen schon mal gab, aber das so
umgesetzt haben, dass plötzlich
andere Sprachen da irgendwie das wieder
ausgraben, würde ich sagen.
Sie haben es geschafft, das so einzubauen,
dass es einem nicht sehr akademisch vorkommt.
Ja, genau.
Und das ist halt in
Haskell anders. Das ist
eine Sprache aus dem akademischen Umfeld und auch
wenn das jetzt plötzlich ganz viele Leute irgendwie
für
Real-World-Anwendungen
einsetzen und
plötzlich auch das Tooling sich irgendwie
deutlich verbessert und man das schon irgendwie merkt,
Leute auch irgendwie
nicht nur Akademiker mehr
irgendwie
Interesse haben,
ist das halt trotzdem noch so.
Das ist halt irgendwie
sehr schade, dass Idris
an ganz anderen Stellen
sehr akademisch ist, weil die halt
irgendwie so diese eigentliche
Sprache ist halt sehr ähnlich zu Heskel und die haben das halt
ziemlich gut aufgeräumt
und haben halt irgendwie so diese ganzen
Ecken und Enden, wo Heskel irgendwie
nicht so geil ist.
dass es zum Beispiel irgendwie 15 verschiedenen Stringtypen
ungefähr gibt,
gefühlt,
haben die halt ausgebügelt.
An welchen anderen Stellen ist es dann
doof?
Das Idris, naja,
eben zum Beispiel an den
Stellen, wo du dann eigentlich
diese Dependent-Types richtig verwenden möchtest
und dann aber an die Grenze kommst,
was der
Typ-Checker
von sich aus kann.
Und da kommst du, glaube ich, in Idris drin,
relativ schnell auch hin, dass du sagst,
ich möchte das eigentlich,
jetzt habe ich mich schon mal an diese Invarianten gewöhnt
und möchte das jetzt auch nutzen und dann
landest du plötzlich wieder in einem Umfeld,
wo das nicht mehr automatisch geht und dann
kann man dann an manchen Stellen,
also ein schönes Feature
bei Rust ist, dass du jetzt deine Funktion
hinschreiben kannst, aber dann ist,
wenn du die noch nicht ausimplementieren möchtest,
kannst du unimplemented reinschreiben
als Makro und dann kompiliert
das trotzdem. Kann man bei Idris dann an solchen Stellen
sagen, hier könnte ein Beweis stehen,
aber ich kann ihn momentan noch nicht hinschreiben.
Glaub mir das erstmal und dann kannst du es vielleicht später machen.
Ja, genau. Also du kannst solche
Holes lassen und du kannst auch
diese Holes, kannst du
darauf checken, was die für
einen Typ haben, um dann halt irgendwie
nachdenken zu können,
was muss da eigentlich hin.
Aber du kannst jetzt dein Programm
nicht umsetzen in ein
ausführbares Programm, bevor
du die nicht gefüllt hast.
Also das ist sozusagen eine Hilfe zur Entwicklung.
Das ist ja unsafe quasi.
Genau. Aber ich glaube halt, dass da irgendwie die eigentliche Wahrheit wird halt irgendwo dazwischen liegen.
Weil nämlich zum Beispiel Idris ist auch erlaubt gegenüber Haskell mit diesem Typen den Code zu vereinfachen.
Ein Beispiel davon ist, dass wenn ich irgendwie versuche etwas mit zwei Listen zu machen, die gleich lang sind.
Also zum Beispiel, ein Standardbeispiel ist so ein ZIP, also Z-I-P, das nimmt zwei Listen der gleichen Länge und gibt eine Liste von Paaren aus, wo immer das erste Element der ersten Liste, genau, das erste Element der ersten Liste bildet ein Paar mit dem ersten Element der zweiten Liste und so weiter.
Und in Haskell würdest du dann halt vier Cases hinschreiben, also vier Fälle.
Nämlich der Fall, dass beide Listen leer sind, der Fall, dass die linke Liste leer ist,
der Fall, dass die rechte Liste leer ist und der Fall, dass in beiden Listen was drin ist.
Gibt es noch den Fall, dass beide unterschiedlich lang sind oder sowas?
Gibt es nicht in Haskell.
Genau, also das ist genau der Punkt. In Haskell weißt du halt nicht, dass die gleich lang sind und deshalb musst du den Fall hinschreiben, dass zum Beispiel nur die linke Liste leer ist oder nur die rechte Liste leer ist. Also rekursiv, wenn du irgendwie das machst sozusagen mit dem ersten Element und dem zweiten Element und dem dritten Element, dass du irgendwo an einem Punkt ankommen kannst, wo jetzt die eine Liste vorbei ist und die andere noch nicht.
Das ist etwas, was du nur zur Runtime weißt und in Idris kannst du das so hinschreiben,
dass das nur kompiliert, wenn du von vornherein weißt, dass die beiden Listen gleich lang sind.
Genau, also in Idris schreibst du halt in die Eingangstypen rein.
Das ist eine Liste der Länge M und das ist eine Liste der Länge M.
Das heißt, die sind gleich und dann muss ich nämlich nur zwei Fälle nur noch hinschreiben.
Aber das verlagert auch deinen Check einfach bloß an einer anderen Stelle im Code, oder?
Ja, möglicherweise. Aber es kann auch gut sein, dass das sich so weit hoch verlagert, dass du es einmal checkst und plötzlich an 50 Stellen du ein einfacheres Leben hast sozusagen.
Wie wird denn das dann gehandhabt, wenn ich zum Beispiel jetzt Input von außen habe? Also wenn ich mit Idris einen Parser schreibe und der parsst ein JSON-Objekt zum Beispiel, da stehen zwei Listen drin, die ich verzippen möchte. Wie wird denn das dann gehandhabt?
Das ist super spannend tatsächlich, weil eigentlich hat man ja irgendwie die naive Vorstellung, dass Typen ein Compile-Zeit-Konstrukt sind und alles andere ist irgendwie ein Runtime-Konstrukt.
Das wäre so meine naive Vorstellung gewesen.
Genau, richtig. Und das ist auch gar nicht so naiv, weil das eigentlich bei allen Programmiersprachen so ist.
Aber in der Typtheorie ist das halt überhaupt nicht so.
Da sind wahrscheinlich die meisten Typen
leben irgendwie im statischen Umfeld,
aber es gibt eben auch Typen,
die eben zur Runtime existieren können.
Und das ist halt genauso ein Fall.
Indem du dann, wenn du I.O. machst,
nehme mir vom Netzwerk oder von der Konsole
irgendwelche Sachen entgegen,
irgendwie so eine Liste,
Und dann muss ich dann halt den Check machen oder so ein Beweisobjekt sozusagen basteln,
dass das, was ich da generiert habe, eben eine bestimmte Länge hat.
Die Pendant Pairs nennt sich das, da verbindest du dann sozusagen das, was du irgendwie angegeben hast,
diese Liste, mit der Eigenschaft diesem Beweisobjekt, das die folgende Länge irgendwie so hat.
Und dann ist dieser Typ sozusagen, zur Runtime existiert er noch.
Und das ist eben aber zum Beispiel ein Fall, wo ich dann so ein Beweisobjekt herumreichen muss.
Also dann habe ich irgendwie ein Beweisding, das schleppe ich halt irgendwie mit
und kann das dann eben an so eine Funktion übergeben und sagen,
hier, übrigens, das hat die gleiche länger.
die beiden Listen, die ich gerade eingegeben habe.
Interessant.
Und das aber eben,
da kommen wir halt so ein bisschen
in die
sehr spannenden, aber
für Normalentwickler
und sexy Bereiche rein, würde ich sagen.
Ja, das sind so die Bereiche.
Template Metaprogramming ist auch hauptsächlich
interessant für Leute, die Bibliotheken
bauen. Aber es ist halt dann auch das Schöne,
was du machen kannst.
Ich möchte natürlich nicht die ganze Zeit
Code schreiben mit den Beweisen und den ausführen.
Aber es ist super gut, wenn du weißt,
dass du Libraries hast, die
ganz strikte Restriktionen
sich auferlegt haben und dass ich,
wenn ich eine Library benutze, dass dann definitiv
das und das und das damit nicht passieren kann.
Und das brauchst du nicht, weil das Ding irgendwie
eine Testsuite hat, die aus 35.000
Zeilen Code besteht, die
oder 35 Mal so viel Zeilen
Code besteht wie der ursprüngliche Code, was
wahrscheinlich noch gar nicht reicht, sondern
weil es einfach statisch gut ausdrückbar ist.
Genau, und also ich denke, dass das cool ist halt
einfach, dass man es machen kann. Also irgendwie
bin halt großer Fan von solchen Ansätzen
wie bei diesem F-Star oder auch
bei Liquid Tesco,
wo man sagt, wir reduzieren
das, was wir ausdrücken können
in den Typen oder diesen Annotationen
und dafür
können wir dann irgendwie das meiste automatisch
machen und
da stößt man halt mit
solchen Ansätzen aber auch an die Grenzen
von dem, was geht, also
IO zum Beispiel und
Idris kann das halt noch, auch wenn das dann halt
super kompliziert wird.
Da muss man halt gucken, ob man
irgendwie mit
so
Frameworks und der Standard-Library,
dass man irgendwie da so Konstrukte
schaffen kann, dass Leute
das auch einsetzen können, ohne halt
diese krasse Magie da zu verstehen.
Aber du kannst zum Beispiel
auf die Art und Weise bestimmt
wesentlich schönere APIs zu
Netzwerksachen
anbieten, weil du dem
Benutzer deines HTTP-Stacks
oder sowas, die Arbeit abnimmst,
gewisse Checks durchzuführen
zum Runtime, wenn sie das benutzen, sondern
das kompiliert halt nur dann, wenn sie
das HTTP-Protokoll auch wirklich
auf eine sinnvolle Art und Weise einsetzen.
Ja.
Genau, und von daher,
irgendwo dazwischen wird halt, glaube ich,
das liegen, was man irgendwann mal auch
einsetzen können wird.
Ich weiß das bei F-Star gar nicht
genau, wo da die Grenzen liegen, ob es da
Grenzen gibt, an die man stößt,
die man nicht lösen kann.
Glücklicherweise haben die eben auch so einen Ansatz,
wo man dann irgendwie manuell weitermachen kann irgendwie.
Das weiß ich nicht genau.
Aber ich habe letztens hier,
gab es eine super spannende Sache auf Twitter.
Da hat irgendwie einen Entwickler von Daphne,
was so eine Sprache ist, auch von Microsoft Research,
aber aus einer ganz anderen Ecke,
die halt irgendwie Verifikationen auf imperativeem Code machen.
Also Daphne ist eine imperative Sprache
und da kann man auch Verifikationen drauf machen.
Und das ist halt, das geht so lange gut, wie du nicht irgendwie arbiträr irgendwelche Heapsachen machst.
Also auf dem Stack geht das häufig noch erstaunlich gut.
Ja gut, Stack ist auch was.
Du kannst halt irgendwie keine Pointer-Magie oder sowas, darfst du halt nicht.
Das Stack geht noch ganz gut ohne Seiten-Effekte.
Ja, genau.
Und sobald du halt irgendwie Sachen dynamisch anlegst,
irgendwie speicherdynamisch anlegst,
wird es dann halt echt schwierig, glaube ich.
Also der hat halt super provokant,
hat irgendwie die These aufgestellt,
hier, man braucht eigentlich gar nicht funktional Programmierung,
um ordentliche formale Verifikation zu machen.
Und damit hat er auch teilweise recht.
Also solange du in bestimmten Grenzen dich...
Solange du dich nicht benutzt.
Ja, genau.
Solange du dich in bestimmten Grenzen bewegst,
so würde ich sagen.
Der braucht schon Vektoren von dynamischer Länge.
Der hat halt irgendwie so drei Funktionen
implementiert gehabt und hat
irgendwie so provokant gesagt, ja hier
Leute,
macht das mal besser in euren Sprachen.
Das haben halt tatsächlich
echt einfach so die ganzen Leute,
die diese ganzen formalen
Verifikationssprachen irgendwie
entwickeln oder daran arbeiten,
haben sich das zu Herzen genommen und haben ihre
Lösungen präsentiert sozusagen. Das war
super spannend.
Weil man da halt das ganz gut sehen konnte.
Zum Beispiel in COG sah das eigentlich ganz nett aus, muss ich sagen.
Aber es war halt irgendwie leider eben separat vom Code, war irgendwie so dieser Beweis.
Weil COG generell separat vom Code ist?
Genau, also da hast du sozusagen deine Invariante, stellst du auf und dann machst du irgendwie wie so auf so einem Zettelpapier,
machst dann irgendwie so Schritte
nacheinander, irgendwie so
Induktion über M
und dann machst du
zwei Fälle und
das ist eigentlich schon
ganz geil auch, das ist halt sehr mächtig,
aber es
hängt halt nicht am Code mit dran,
ist daher auch
eher so ein...
Es muss schon auch wirklich mit dabei sein,
sonst kann man es nicht wirklich benutzen.
Ich glaube auch, dass
seltener, würde ich sagen, deshalb
in der Praxis benutzt wird.
Und
was wollte ich jetzt eigentlich sagen?
Ah ja, genau.
Diese Challenge hat er aufgestellt.
Und da hat man schon gesehen,
dass halt echt
viele von diesen formalen
Beweisen waren halt echt
lang, muss ich sagen. Und sehr
schwer zu verstehen. Das Schlimmste war ein ACDA.
ACDA war eh kacke.
Was ist das?
ACDA ist A-G-D-A.
hat nichts mit ADA zu tun.
ADA kenne ich noch,
aber es ist nichts damit zu tun,
dann ist das nicht.
Auch eine dependency-typed Sprache,
älter als Idris
und sehr akademisch
und syntaktisch
sehr schwer zu verstehen, würde ich sagen.
Bei ADA kann man aber auch
Vor- und Nachbedingungen an seine Funktionen
heranschreiben. Genau, das ist ziemlich ähnlich
wie Idris im Endeffekt.
Aber auch schon älter
und auch komplett aus dem akademischen Umfeld raus.
Und es gab echt super, schwer zu verstehende Lösungen.
Teilweise kürzer als hier die in diesem Daphne,
die auch nicht so besonders prickelnd war, fand ich.
Und dann hat man halt gesehen in diesem F-Star,
was ich eben genannt habe,
hier von diesem Project Everest,
da von Microsoft Research.
Und in dem Liquid Haskell, also beides so Sprachen,
die alles, was geht, irgendwie automatisiert machen,
war das halt richtig schick.
Das war kürzer, also quasi Logik-Golfen.
Genau.
Genau, also teilweise mussten die halt wirklich nur einfach die Innenvarianten dran schreiben und meinten, fertig.
Und das hat bei zwei Funktionen gut geklappt, bei einer nicht so gut, aber selbst da war es noch verständlich, was sie ausdrücken wollten sozusagen.
Und das kommt dann schon echt so in den Bereich, wo ich sagen würde, wenn man da noch ein bisschen Tooling drumherum baut
und das irgendwie ein bisschen verfeinert,
dann kann man das irgendwann auch anwenden.
Könnte alles so viel einfacher sein.
Bugfreier Code.
Ja, krass. Cool.
So, wir haben jetzt
Functional Programming,
finde ich ziemlich gut zusammengefasst.
Nicht nur, warte mal, also nicht nur Functional Programming,
von Functional Programming
haben wir vor einer Stunde geredet.
Dann kam erst auf
Typsysteme. Wir haben jetzt also Functional
Programming und Typsysteme, das sind schon ziemlich
hart abgefrühstückt, muss ich sagen,
und das in die Tageszeit.
Und jetzt,
das ist ja aber trotzdem so ein,
das sind Konzepte,
die auf
kleine Strukturen innerhalb von
einem Programm
stattfinden, also haben sie auf
Konzepte innerhalb vom Hauptspeicher, ich kriege
was rein, was entweder SDDIO ist,
also IOS-Netzwerk
vom Speicher
arbeite ich, dann bleibe ich aber innerhalb
von meiner Prozessgrenze.
Du hast vorher in der Einleitung
schon gemeint, du hast die auch sehr intensiv
mit
Distributed Processing
auseinandergesetzt und es ist
ein Konzept,
was aus der Vorlesung
Distributed Systems
ein Konzept aus der Vorlesung
Distributed Systems war
dieser klassische Beispiel
MapReduce-Algorithmus
von Google, dass man
verteilt
auf Operationen, auf Daten
macht und die dann einfach immer weiter
ergibt und darauf gemappt wird
und es dann zum Schluss zu dem Ergebnis reduced wird.
Ist das schon Stream
Processing? Nein.
Also es gibt
eine gut aufgestellte Frage.
Ich bedanke mich
für die Frage.
Aber das ist ein sehr
funktionales Konzept, was mir
dann später erst aufgefallen ist.
Genau, richtig.
Völlig falsch, Hendrik.
Absolut funktionales Konzept und
denke ich auch die Brücke zu Stream Processing.
Also es
haben sich in
der Distributed Systems
Welt, also die
nicht nur irgendwie so ein bisschen
Distributed, so irgendwie im Sinne
von Erlang macht, irgendwie so über
eine Maschine
zweite Maschine oder sowas,
sondern wo es irgendwie darum geht, dass man
irgendwie, glaube ich, viele Datenmengen
abzuarbeiten hat.
Ich denke, zwei Konzepte
irgendwie
herausgearbeitet mit der Zeit und
das Batch Processing
und Stream Processing.
Und MapReduce war,
glaube ich,
vielleicht wäre ich dafür auch geschlagen, aber
war, glaube ich,
einer der ersten
Vertreter von diesem Batch Processing.
Und Batch Processing ist die Idee, dass man eben in diesem Fall Map und Reduce-Operationen irgendwie miteinander verbinden konnte.
Am Anfang war es nur ein Map, also ich teile irgendwie meine Daten, die ich habe, teile ich auf.
Ich mache zum Beispiel eine Suchanfrage, ich habe meinen gesamten Index über das Internet und darüber filtre ich erstmal drüber
und dann mappe ich das nach Relevanz,
also sortiere ich das nach Relevanz
und dann fasse ich es zusammen zu irgendeinem aggregierten Wert oder sowas.
Das sind ja sozusagen Map-Introduce.
Die Idee daran ist halt immer,
dass ich diesen Map-Operator einmal definiere
und dass ich den aber ganz oft sozusagen dupliziere dann
und dass ich meine Daten irgendwie partitioniere, die ich reingebe.
Also dass ich irgendwie, wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel Facebook bin
und alle meine User-Daten irgendwie einmal durch irgendeine Analyse,
irgendeine Analyse-Maschine aus Cambridge durchziehen möchte,
dann würde ich halt sagen, naja, irgendwie hier Nutzer A bis F
gehen auf den ersten Map-Operator
und f bis
keine Ahnung was, gehen auf die zweiten und so weiter.
Also ich muss irgendwie,
möchte ich halt irgendwie eine Parallelisierung haben
und ich möchte das
in
zwei Dimensionen, würde ich sagen,
parallelisieren. Nämlich einmal,
indem ich die Daten partitioniere
und das zweite ist, dass ich das
Pipeline-Parallelisierung
mache. Also
so bei MapReduce, ganz am Anfang
hat man nur einen
Map-Schritt machen können und einen Reduce-Schritt
machen können und dann hat man es irgendwie abgespeichert.
Dann konnte man wieder ein Map und
ein Reduce machen und mit
der Zeit ist es dann ein bisschen
flexibler geworden und
so, denke ich, der bekannteste
Vertreter ist Apache Spark,
die
im Endeffekt das Gleiche, was
MapReduce gemacht hat, nur sehr viel
ausdefinierter. Also du kannst halt
so einen ganzen Abarbeitungsbaum
definieren mit Quellen
und senken sozusagen.
Und bei den Quellen kommen irgendwo von irgendwo anders
deine Daten rein. Und bei den senken
kommen halt deine Resultate raus.
Dazwischen kannst du Operatoren
arbiträr
definieren und miteinander verbinden.
Das heißt, da kannst du irgendwie entweder so
Map und Reuse
verwenden, da kannst du aber auch Filter
verwenden und
alles, was irgendwie aus SQL rauskommt,
irgendwie so
Select und Join und
Merge und alle möglichen Sachen.
kannst du dann irgendwie auf diesen Streams machen.
Ne, nicht auf den Streams,
auf diesen Badges machen.
Und der Unterschied zwischen
Badge-Processing... Was ist denn jetzt ein Badge?
Genau, ein Badge ist sozusagen
eine...
Also bei Badge-Processing
habe ich endliche Daten.
Also zum Beispiel die User
von Facebook, die sind endlich.
Und
dann kann ich die halt partitionieren
und habe sozusagen
alle Nutzer von A bis F
und das ist ein
endliches Paket.
Das ist vielleicht kein gutes Beispiel,
weil es halt ein sehr großes Paket ist,
aber man kann ja auch sagen,
User von...
Das ist vor allem ungleichmäßig,
gerade in der chinesischen Welt
kommt dann bei XYZ nochmal eine ganze Menge.
Und
was ich mit diesem Batch mache,
ist, dass ich den einmal
als Gesamtes durch diesen ersten Operator
durchschicke, also durch diesen
Map-Operator. Und
bei den anderen Schritten genauso.
Dann muss ich irgendwie
meinen Reduce kann ich dann erst
ausführen, sobald
diese ganzen Map-Operatoren,
sobald die fertig sind.
Und dann
kann ich halt sozusagen, wenn ich
diese ganzen Pakete
gesammelt habe, dann schicke ich die
alle in einem Schritt durch
das Reduce durch.
Und das ist trotzdem
Pipeline-Parallelismus, weil ich nämlich
den ersten Map-Operator
kann ich dann schon wieder verwenden für neue Daten,
für einen neuen Batch,
während der
Reduce-Operator
noch die Daten vom letzten Schritt
verarbeitet. Das sind dann die nächsten Daten,
die dann schon kommen. Genau, das sind die nächsten Daten,
die schon kommen. Und Stream Processing
ist eigentlich wirklich fast das Gleiche,
nur dass man halt sagt,
ich schicke jedes einzelne Datum,
was irgendwie
in diesem großen Haufen hatte,
schicke ich direkt weiter zu den nächsten Operatoren.
Und manchmal hat man blockierende Operatoren,
die müssen dann halt warten,
bis irgendwie so bestimmte Daten angekommen sind
von unterschiedlichen Eingängen oder sowas.
Aber ganz häufig hat man das auch nicht.
Ganz häufig hat man einfach irgendwelche Pipelines,
wo einfach nur Events durchlaufen
und irgendwie entweder miteinander verbunden werden
oder einzeln verändert werden.
Ist das von Konzepten her schon irgendwie vergleichbar
mit so
Iteratoren
also Arbeiten
auf Iteratoren, einmal eager und einmal
lazy, ist das etwa
ähnlich? Genau, das ist
eigentlich ziemlich eins zu eins
vergleichbar, nur dass es halt
sozusagen im verteilten Umfeld
ist sozusagen
und
dass du halt
also
keine Ahnung, bei einer lazy Sprache
jetzt zum Beispiel, kann es halt
manchmal passieren, dass bestimmte Teile
überhaupt nicht ausgeführt werden.
Das kann dir da nur
passieren, wenn da keine Daten hinkommen.
Na gut, vielleicht tatsächlich ein ziemlich ähnliches
Prinzip. Also ich habe sowas
neulich zum Spaß mal selber implementiert.
In schönen Sprachen
gibt es das ja schon. In TypeScript gab es
Lazy-Iteratoren, zumindest in der Sprache noch nicht.
Das war nicht mal an so einem Tag,
an dem ich gerade zu Hause geblieben bin, habe ich dann
Lazy-Iteratoren in TypeScript geschrieben.
Und das Problem, was einem dann auffällt, ist, dass man
Dadurch, dass man erst zum Schluss was ausführt, sammelst du deine vorherigen Schritte und die Operation darauf bis ganz zum Ende eigentlich ein.
Das heißt, wenn ich jetzt hinter einen Filter hinter einen Map schalte, bekomme ich zum Schluss einen Typ raus, das ist ein Iterator, ein Map-Iterator von einem Filteroperator, von einem Filteroperator, von meiner eigentlichen Geschichte.
Wie lässt sich das auf verteilte Systeme übertragen?
Ich möchte das ja nicht komplett sammeln,
ich möchte das ja trotzdem irgendwie stateless weitergeben können.
Genau, also sowas funktioniert halt wirklich nur im Single-Threaded-Umfeld sozusagen.
Und in diesem Fall funktioniert es halt eher wie in so einer Fabrik.
Also du hast halt die einzelnen Abarbeitungsschritte
und du hast irgendwie ein Laufband dazwischen
und deine Daten gehen halt irgendwie
oder deine
Sachen, die du abarbeitest,
gehen halt irgendwie so die einzelnen
Schritte lang
und werden immer mal verändert oder werden miteinander
kombiniert, irgendwie so zwei Teile oder sowas
und dann musst du halt eventuell mal
auf einen Teil warten oder so,
das blockieren und dann schickst du das
irgendwie verändert weiter,
aber die existieren halt alle gleichzeitig,
das ist schon ein normaler Pipeline-Parallelismus,
während halt irgendwie
wenn da irgendwie lazy
irgendwas abarbeitest,
dann
existieren da nicht mehrere
Abarbeitungsschritte, sondern es ist
im Endeffekt ein großer
Abarbeitungsschritt, der einfach
alles hintereinander macht sozusagen,
ohne Zwischenergebnisse abzuspeichern.
Das ist das coole,
also gerade in Elixir
ist das sehr cool umgesetzt,
dieses Lazy
Arbeiten auf Listen
zum Beispiel oder auf irgendwelchen Datenstrukturen,
Das sind nämlich, es gibt zwei Module und das eine Modul ist IGA und das andere Modul ist Lazy, das nennt sich Stream.
Also das IGA-Modul heißt Enum und das andere heißt Stream und die haben fast komplett identische Funktionen mit.
Also das heißt, du kannst sozusagen das erstmal IGA schreiben und kannst einfach das Modul austauschen und das ist alles lazy.
Das ist eigentlich ziemlich cool. Aber der Unterschied ist tatsächlich, dass da im Endeffekt hast du deine Pipeline ist im Endeffekt eine Computation irgendwie so.
Und bei Stream Processing liegen diese einzelnen Schritte nicht zusammen,
sondern möglicherweise auf komplett unterschiedlichen Rechnern drauf.
Und dann ist sozusagen dieses Laufband das weiterschicken,
was wir im Netzwerk von einem Server zum anderen.
Und das Coole ist halt, dass dieses Thema halt irgendwie so Sachen wie Falterans drin haben.
Also wenn irgendwas abstürzt, dann haben die so Sicherungssysteme drin, dass der halt dann zurückrollt bis zu dem letzten Stand, der irgendwie lokal verfügbar war und ab dem Zeitpunkt dann wieder weitermacht, nur halt irgendwie mit, dass dieser Abarbeitungsschritt dann möglicherweise auf einem komplett anderen Server läuft, weil vielleicht der eine Server gerade hat jemanden ein Stück an der Hand gehabt und wusste nicht, wohin der gehört.
Du hast jetzt für
Batches-Thema Apache Sparkle gezählt
und da stell ich mir dann vor,
da gibt es halt wirklich eine Kiste, die nur die
eine Operation ausführt und dann
an die nächste Kiste weiterreicht, die dann
die nächste Operation
zum Beispiel ausführt. Bei
Stream Processing klang das jetzt so, als müsste man
die Art von Operation, die auf einem
bestimmten Datenset als nächstes ausgeführt werden muss,
quasi mitreichen, damit
der Nächste weiß, was er zu tun hat?
Ne, die sind also
Das cool ist, dass du halt vorher in so einer Art DSL irgendwie relativ funktional definieren kannst, was du so machen willst.
Und dieses System kümmert sich dann darum, dass deine einzelnen, würde ich sagen, funktionalen Abarbeitungsschritte auf die verfügbaren Server verteilt werden,
dass die vielleicht irgendwie mehrfach vorhanden sind oder wenigstens, dass die neu gestartet werden, wenn irgendwo was fehlt.
der konfiguriert die dann auch so,
dass die einzelnen Schritte nicht direkt wissen müssen,
wo sie ihre Daten weiterreichen,
sondern die geben die einfach raus
und dann gibt es irgendwie einen kleinen Software-Teil,
der dann konfiguriert ist,
der weiß, wo es als nächstes hingeht sozusagen.
Du sagst gerade der,
wir haben jetzt wie gesagt bei Batch
ein konkretes System genannt.
Kannst du mal beim Stream Processing
irgendwie so prominente Vertreter aufzählen?
Genau, also ich habe konkret
Flink gearbeitet.
Apache Flink.
Das ist sozusagen das Pendant, würde ich sagen.
In
Streaming. Das kann auch schon
fast alles, was Spark kann, nur dass
Spark halt riesig und groß und bekannt
ist und viele Firmenvertreter hinter hat.
Und bei Flink fängt das, denke ich,
erst langsam an.
Das heißt,
es ist einfach eine neue Generation,
diese Streaming-Systeme. Die können die Batch-Systeme
werden, die irgendwann komplett ersetzen können, aber
noch ist es nicht ganz so weit.
Und ich habe halt in meiner Diplomarbeit
natürlich eine Erweiterung gemacht,
die dazu eventuell beiträgt.
Vorher war es halt super schwierig,
in solchen Streaming-Systemen Loops zu haben.
Brauchtest du auch teilweise gar nicht,
weil so Loops,
die du halt normalerweise beim Programmieren verwendest
oder dann funktional irgendwie Rekursionen,
wo eine Iteration nicht von der vorherigen abhängig ist,
die kannst du halt komplett parallelisieren.
Also das heißt, da kannst du einfach
fünf Varianten von einem Operator machen
und die machen das gleichzeitig,
statt eins nach dem anderen die Iterationen von dieser Loop zu machen.
Also so Loop Unrolling mäßig.
Und
das,
genau, also
an vielen Stellen brauchst du das dann doch.
Also es gibt ganz viele
Schleifen, die du halt schreiben
würdest, wo dann doch der
nächste Schritt
am aktuellen irgendwie dranhängt,
mit irgendeiner Datendependency.
Und
zwei Beispiele, wo das halt immer
der Fall ist, sind
so Graph-Algorithmen, wo du halt
so iterativ irgendwie von einem Knoten ausgehend irgendwas durchsuchst, so einen Graphen.
Oder Machine Learning, wo du halt sagst, in jedem Schritt nehme ich ein neues Datenobjekt
und lerne irgendwas daran und habe dann einen Lernerfolg.
Und diesen Lernerfolg möchte ich wieder zurückgehen sozusagen
und möchte das Gleiche wieder machen mit dem nächsten Datenobjekt.
Und da habe ich halt eingebaut, dass man solche Loops machen kann, was nicht ganz so einfach ist, weil du in solchen Stream-Processing-Systemen brauchst du immer einen messbaren Fortschritt sozusagen.
Das beste Beispiel ist, denke ich, dieser Reduce-Operator.
Du musst aber einen Iterator mitzählen oder einen Index mitzählen.
Ja, so ein bisschen. Das Einfachste ist vielleicht, wenn man...
mal ein konkretes Beispiel zum Festhalten
geben für sowas? Also ich habe jetzt natürlich
Cambridge Analytica vor Augen,
weil wir auch
von Facebook geredet haben, aber was ist denn zum Beispiel
ein Einsatzgebiet für Stream Processing?
Also alles immer so
Big Data Anwendungen.
Genau, also
beziehungsweise du kannst das halt auch
verwenden, einfach wenn du
von, ich würde sagen,
verteilten Systemen nicht so
viel Ahnung hast und trotzdem
eins schreiben möchtest, weil das halt
dir viel Sachen abnimmt.
Genau das, was man machen sollte.
Keine Ahnung, halt einfach trotzdem mal schreiben.
Ja, gut, dafür ist ja
Abstraktion da,
wenn sie funktioniert.
Genau, also du kannst auch
zum Beispiel Facebook damit nachbauen, wenn du
das möchtest. Du kannst halt
irgendwie sagen, so alles, was meine Nutzer
machen. Anruf an die Zuhörer,
bitte baut Facebook nach.
Genau, also
alles, was ein Nutzer macht,
kann halt ein Stream von Events sein.
Und so ein Event kann halt sein,
irgendwie ich lade ein Katzenfoto hoch
oder ich, weiß nicht,
hate so ein bisschen auf Minderheiten rum oder sowas.
Also was man halt so auf Facebook macht.
Genau, das wird dann direkt statisch evaluiert
und dann direkt nach Dev0 gepipet.
Genau, und wenn du halt irgendwie so diese ganzen Sachen,
die so ein Nutzer macht, ist ja ein unendlicher
Stream. Und das ist auch der Vorteil von den
Stream-Processing-Systemen gegenüber den Batch-Processing-Systemen.
Die Batch-Systeme brauchen immer
ein endliches Datenpaket
und die Streaming-Systeme,
die funktionieren halt mit unendlichen Daten.
Die müssen sich immer mal wieder resetten
und beim U-Anfangen und dann wieder mit dem ersten
Batch anfangen. Genau.
So ein Stream kann einfach so
ein Durchlauberhitze haben.
Und dann gibt es aber so ein paar Operationen,
da funktioniert das nicht
nicht ganz so gut, dass man einfach so die Daten
durchstreamt. Also irgendwie so ein Map
ist noch irgendwie relativ cool, da kann
das einfach eine Funktion, die ich auf jede
Eingabe anwende und dann gebe ich die Ausgabe
raus, aber so ein Reduce ist schon wieder nicht so gut,
weil so ein Reduce ist halt
häufiger, dass ich irgendwie so eine Aggregation mache,
also zum Beispiel, dass ich eine Summe
bilde. Jetzt fragt man
sich natürlich eine Summe, worüber eigentlich,
wenn das jetzt irgendwie ein unendlicher
Stream ist, dann ist die ja nie fertig so.
Die Summe aller
Zahlen ist übrigens
minus 1,12.
Was?
Ich bin mal bekannt für so.
Ich dachte, so ein Numberphile-Video
würde ich das bewiesen haben. Das ist allerdings auch dann
in fünf anderen Videos herrlich die Bank
worden. Ich wollte jetzt nicht zu weit.
Genau, also so ein
Reduce, also zum Beispiel
so ein Summ-Operator, der muss
halt irgendwie wissen, wann er
mal eine Ausgabe machen soll.
Und da kommt halt dieser...
Man definiert Schluss sein.
Genau, oder mal ein Cut dazwischen sozusagen.
Und genau das ist halt dieser Progress,
dass du halt diesem Operator signalisierst,
wenn irgendwie so bestimmte Epochen von Daten zum Beispiel durch sind.
Oder wenn bestimmte Daten, wenn die alle einen Timestamp haben.
Dann machen wir fünf Minuten einen Cut.
Genau, also der diesem Operator halt sagen kann,
naja, hier mit Timestamp unter 15 kommt jetzt nichts mehr.
weil die nämlich halt arbiträr umgeordnet sein können.
Also wenn du hier irgendwie so ein dicht verzweigtes Netz von solchen Operatoren hast,
dann kann es halt irgendwie auch so sein, dass irgendwie zu einem Operator kommen.
Da gibt es halt mehrere Wege.
Und das heißt, die können sich zeitlich komplett umordnen
und dann brauchst du halt irgendwas, was so ein bisschen so eine Art globale Sicht darauf hat
und dann den einzelnen Operatoren sagen kann,
hier, unter
15 kommt jetzt nichts mehr,
wenn du jetzt also irgendwelche
Summen hast, die du irgendwie
machen möchtest,
also zum Beispiel sowas
wie alle Timestamps von 1
bis 13
zu summieren und daraus
eine Ausgabe zu machen,
die dann den Stream weiterläuft,
dann kannst du das erst machen.
Und das ist halt so
diese Fortschrittsmessungen,
die brauchen
Stream-Persessing-Systeme,
die blockierende Operatoren erlauben.
Blockierende Operatoren sind super wichtig.
Und das war halt
eben auch das Problem, wenn du irgendwie
so einen Loop
dann drin hast, dann
können halt
Datenpunkte mit einem Timestamp,
die schon längst an einem Punkt
irgendwie vorbei sind, also zum Beispiel in diesem
Body, würde ich sagen,
können dann sozusagen zurück in der Zeit
reisen, weil sie hinten dann
irgendwo nicht ausgegeben werden
zu irgendeiner Senke, sondern
durch so einen Rückwärtsschritt
wieder irgendwie am Anfang
ankommen. Also wie so ein Loop halt sozusagen.
Also wir haben so ein paar Operatoren
und am Ende haben wir irgendwie...
Nach dem Motto, dich haben wir vergessen, geh da, mach doch mal
dort rein. Das war zwar schon fertig,
aber jetzt machen wir das mal neu.
Genau, also im Endeffekt,
wie bei so einer
Do-While-Schleife, wo dann, wenn du
durch die Schleife durch bist,
gesagt wird, naja, hier, wenn
folgende Bedingung
noch nicht
wahr ist oder sowas, oder immer noch
wahr ist, dann geh zurück
zum Anfang der
Schleife und ansonsten kannst du rausgehen.
Und in dem Fall
geh zurück zum Anfang der Schleife,
reißen eben dann Datenpunkte,
die durch die Body-Operatoren
eigentlich schon durch waren,
und nach den alten Fortschrittsmessungssystemen
würden die halt dann schon benachrichtigt werden.
Hier, Punkt 15 kommt nicht mehr und nichts mehr drunter.
Und dann kann es sein, dass Punkt 12 gerade Happy
einmal durch den Loopbody durch war
und jetzt aber zurückreist an den Anfang
durch so einen Rückwärtsstream sozusagen.
Und dann hat er irgendwie schon seine ganzen Aggregationen gemacht
irgendwie für unter 15.
Und dann kam plötzlich wieder so ein 12 an.
Das ist halt nicht so cool.
Und da habe ich dieses Progress-Measurement sozusagen
habe ich verändert, dass dann korrekte Aussagen getroffen wurden
und an diese Operatoren gesandt wurden.
Genau, das ist halt ein
kleiner Punkt, denke ich,
der jetzt
eventuell irgendwann mal einziehen wird
in so die
Streaming-Systeme, dass solche Sachen gehen.
Vielleicht auf die Art
und Weise, wie ich das gemacht habe. Vielleicht werden
sich noch ganz andere Möglichkeiten finden.
Aber diese Lücke
schließt sich halt. Und
wenn die Streaming-Systeme
all das können, was die Batch-Systeme
heute können, dann sind die
Batch-Systeme meiner Meinung nach
obsolet, weil
du sämtliche Batch-Aufgaben
auch sinnvoll mit einem Streaming-System machen kannst,
aber nicht andersrum. Also du kannst nicht irgendwie
kleinteilig
unendliche Eingaben,
also alles, was irgendwie ein Nutzer von
sich gibt zum Beispiel, oder alles,
was irgendwie Sensoren, hier Internet
of Things oder sowas, das sind ja alles
unendliche Streams,
die die ganze Zeit werden neue Daten produziert,
die irgendwie aggregiert und zusammengefasst
und irgendwo hingeschrieben werden sollen.
Das kann halt so ein Streaming-System gut machen
und vor allem kannst du das halt
irgendwie
einigermaßen funktional,
sehr abstrakt runterschreiben,
kannst es so ein bisschen konfigurieren und
im besten Fall funktioniert das einfach, ohne dass
du dir über irgendwie
Konsistenz
und viele andere Sachen,
die halt hart sind an
des Spieltons Systems
große Gedanken machen musst.
Verteilt sich dann von alleine auf die Wolke.
Genau, also es kann natürlich
sein, dass das System das nicht
perfekt macht und dann brauchst du wieder irgendwelche
Experten, die das gut einstellen, aber
für einfache Anwendungsfälle
bis zu so ein paar
Millionen Nutzern kann das
auch ein Leier.
Na dann,
fange ich mal an Facebook nachzubauen.
Das ist echt faszinierend.
Das ist alles
überhaupt nie mit auseinandergesetzt, aber
ein bisschen mehr dazu anlesen.
Spannend.
Naja, du hast doch jetzt
bereits deine
Sprachanalyse-Software
die Tweets liest
und kannst du quasi
damit...
Das Projekt.
Die wirklich was rausgeworden ist.
Jetzt kannst du damit ganz Twitter pausen.
Sowieso, klar.
Sehr toll, Twitter-Abi, die es bloß
einen Euro pro Anfrage kostet.
Ja, da hat man
wieder die real existierenden
Grenzen auferlegt, nämlich das
Geld kostet was mitmachen.
Ja, super abgefahren. Vielen lieben Dank,
Mario. Das war sehr, sehr,
sehr, sehr, sehr spannend. Wir sind jetzt echt
vom tiefsten, niedrigen,
grundlegendsten auf ein
konkretes Anwendungsfeld gekommen. Das fand ich ziemlich cool.
Doch schon bereits
eine sehr lange
Folge. Ja, das stimmt.
Es tut mir leid.
Nee, ganz klasse.
Ganz klasse, finde ich richtig gut.
Und weil wir jetzt schon
weil unsere Zuhörer bis jetzt
durchgehalten haben,
finde ich, sollten wir jetzt noch mal eine kleine Belohnungsrunde
einführen. Deswegen kommen wir jetzt zu den
Was machen wir jetzt?
Du wolltest doch die Pics am Ende noch als Auflockerung machen.
Genau.
Also ziehen wir uns noch ein paar Pics rein.
Und zwar unsere GitHub-Stars
der Woche. Ich muss sagen, ich muss mich so ein bisschen
zurückhalten, weil ich nämlich die letzten
zwei Wochen fast vollständig mit Umziehen
habe und dementsprechend
Ich habe Zeit zum GitHub-Feed-Lesen
gehabt. Relativ wenig Zeit zum GitHub-Feed-Lesen
gehabt habe, aber
ihr habt doch bestimmt ein Angebot.
Wollen wir mit dem Gast anfangen?
Ja, lustigerweise
habe ich das, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe, habe ich es schon erwähnt.
Das ist dieses
HACL-Star,
das auch ein bisschen
geflunkert hat, weil ich das gar nicht gestartet habe.
Das könnte ich dann gleich einfach nochmal machen.
Aber dass diese
Krypto,
diese Implementierung von diesen
Kryptofunktionen in F-Star
von Microsoft Research,
was jetzt in Teilen im Firefox drin ist.
Ziemlich cool. Seit welchem
Firefox?
57, 58?
Sowas.
Also auf jeden Fall schon
ein Quantum
stark, nicht schlecht.
Ziemlich cool.
Kean?
Ja, die Picks von mir haben
jetzt nicht wirklich sehr viel mit der Thematik zu tun.
Die stehen wir schon länger auf der Liste.
Das ist jetzt ja auch die Cooldown-Phase.
Ja, die wollte ich schon länger mal erwähnen.
Eigentlich wollte ich mich mal thematisch sogar kurz drüber ansprechen,
aber das lohnt sich gar nicht mehr so sehr.
Jetzt kann man alles Piction abhandeln.
Das eine ist ein toller Service, der nennt sich Hyper.sh.
Das ist quasi eine Art Hoster für deine Software.
Bloß, dass du den halt Docker-Container direkt hinhaust.
Und du sagst quasi, hier ist ein Container, lass den mal laufen.
und die berechnen dich halt wirklich nur in Sekunden,
wie lange das Ding gelaufen ist.
Und die haben zwei nette Features,
bis dahin kannst du es mit jedem anderen Moster auch machen,
aber zwei nette Features, die ich recht cool fand,
ist, dass die einerseits deinen Container auch als
wie eine Art Cron-Job laufen lassen können.
Das heißt, du definierst einen Container,
der eine bestimmte Sache tut und dann wieder exitet
und lässt das halt zu regelmäßigen Zeitintervallen laufen.
Das ist ganz nett.
Und das andere ist so ein bisschen an Features wie AWS Lambda angelehnt
oder quasi andere Services machen das ja auch,
wo du einen Container definierst,
der einen bestimmten Inputwert hat,
was irgendwas an Daten raushaut
und das Ganze einfach nur startest
mit einem gewissen Inputwert,
dann wartet, dass es fertig ist
und dann nimmst du den Output
und machst damit, was du immer du machen möchtest.
Das ist jetzt keine Ahnung,
die das Umrechnen von dem Bild ist
oder was weiß ich,
diverse Beispiele, die man da anwenden kann.
Man hat ja auch so ein schönes,
gewisses funktionales Feeling,
wo man da einfach so eine,
ich komme mal hier mit so Begriffen wie Serverless,
aber ich habe noch nie viel davon gehalten,
aber dass man halt
einen Container definiert, der wirklich bloß
aufgrund von seinen Input-Daten irgendwas macht,
ohne irgendwo noch State zu haben, das ist eigentlich
recht schick und ich finde es cool, dass die
einem da halt die Möglichkeit geben, dass man das einfach
über Docker definiert hinlegt
und dann nur für die Sekunden bezahlt,
dieses Ding tatsächlich zur Ausführung gebraucht hat.
Das ist ein recht nettes Feature,
finde ich cool.
So ist es schon minimal, das Angegang
für mal ausprobiert gehabt.
Aber als ich bisher
noch nicht so den Anwendungsfall, aber trotzdem cool.
Ja, dieses AWS Lambda
ist übrigens, glaube ich,
ein fast vollwertiges Stream Processing System
auch. Das habe ich mir fast gesagt.
Es geht in eine recht ähnliche Richtung.
Ich wollte gerade nicht mit einem, der hatte Angst heraus,
dass das vielleicht doch ein nächster Garten ist, aber
es ist halt einfach gehostet.
Also genauso wie dieses Google
Cloud Computing ist auch
Stream Processing. Nur, dass du es halt nicht
selber hosten kannst. Praktisch.
Gibt es, abgesehen von
Flink, noch andere Lösungen, die man selber
könnte?
Ja, also es gibt
das eher akademische Ecke,
würde ich sagen, Timely Dataflow.
Die tun sich
durch einen
sehr abgefahrenen
Progress-Tracking-Algorithmus
aus,
was eben ja auch mein Thema war,
was ich damit anders gelöst habe.
Das wollte ich gar nicht erwähnen, das ist nämlich
in Rust geschrieben.
Genau, das ist
Frank McSherry.
Den habe ich auch mehrfach getroffen, tatsächlich.
Das ist eigentlich ein ganz lustiger Typ.
Genau, und es gibt halt noch,
scheiße, wie hieß das denn?
Es gibt so ein Meta-Ding,
auch ein Apache-Projekt.
Machen wir dann in die Shownotes rein.
Das ist interessant,
weil da auch zum Teil Google
und die Flink-Leute hinterstehen.
Und da kannst du
relativ abstrakt solche Sachen definieren
und kannst hinterher sagen, okay, ich möchte das
als Batch
abgearbeitet haben oder ich möchte das als Streaming
abgearbeitet haben.
Also wenn du unendliche Daten hast,
hast du keine Wahl, aber wenn du endliche Daten
hast, hast du eine Wahl.
Und kannst auch das Backend sozusagen
austauschen.
Kannst das halt entweder, wenn du es,
also ich glaube, der Haupteinsatzzweck
ist, wenn du sagst, wir hosten
das alles und benutzen Flink zum Beispiel
und
irgendwann wird es uns zu groß
und unser Admin ist vor den Bus gelaufen oder sowas,
dann gehen wir halt zu Google
und können aber das genauso, wie es implementiert ist,
weiter nutzen.
Und es gab halt noch Storm von Twitter.
Das ist aber, glaube ich, relativ tot,
weil sie einfach nicht so mit den aktuellen Entwicklungen
mitgehalten haben.
Obwohl Twitter eigentlich eine riesengute Anwendung
für Stream-Processing ist.
Auf jeden Fall. Die benutzen intern
irgendwie Nachfolger,
Heron oder irgendwie sowas,
kann man auch mit reinmachen.
Habe ich aber nicht viel von gehört und
glaube ich auch, außer bei Twitter, irgendwo benutzt.
Und es gibt,
also was vielleicht mit
so auch die spannendste Entwicklung
ist,
die Leute, die das hauptsächlich mit
angefangen haben mit dem Stream Processing, sind
die Kafka-Leute, Apache Kafka.
Und da hängt Apache
Samson mit dran, das ursprünglich aus LinkedIn
innen rausgekommen, dieses Projekt.
Die haben es intern ganz lange
benutzt und haben dann gesagt, naja, das muss
aus eigenes werden, das ist eine gute Idee.
Aber LinkedIn hat doch gar nicht so viel Traffic.
Ja, deshalb haben sie
wahrscheinlich gesagt, wir brauchen andere Anwendungsfelder.
Aber da fehlt mir jetzt, wo du gerade noch
das Konzept erwähnst,
ich kann das Backend austauschen
und einfach auf ein anderes Stream Processing
System umziehen.
Apache Lambda zum Beispiel ist ja
eigentlich, ich schreibe da,
Amazon Lambda ist ja ein System,
Ich schreibe da einfach JavaScript und lasse das irgendwo laufen zum Beispiel.
Aber wir haben jetzt den Bogen noch nicht komplett zugemacht.
Wir haben von Stream Processing geredet,
was ein bisschen noch wie so Konzepte von funktionalem Programmieren an sich hat.
Und wir haben vorher lange von funktionalen Programmiersprachen geredet.
In was für Sprachen programmiere ich denn zum Beispiel so ein Apache Flink
und meinen gesamten Stream Processing Ablauf,
dass ich das dann hinterher übernehmen kann?
Genau.
Schreibe ich da ein Stück Code oder konfiguriere ich das?
Genau, also
das schreibt man schon in Code
also Flink kannst du jetzt
in Java und in Scala verwenden
das ist halt JVM
wahrscheinlich auch noch in anderen Sprachen, die irgendwie auf der JVM
benutzen, aber
da habe ich dann ein Stück Library
wo ich mir dann bestimmt
Iteratoren oder Senken oder Quellen ausstelle
Genau, also es sind halt irgendwie Datentypen
meine Quellen sind halt
spezielle Operatoren, meine Senken
sind spezielle Operatoren und
die ganzen Operatoren, die implementiert sind,
sind Operatoren und
dann kann ich halt irgendwie einen
Input-Stream oder viele
Input-Streams anlegen und kann halt irgendwie die Quelle
nennen sozusagen. Das kann halt irgendwo aus dem Internet
kommen oder es kann von der Festplatte kommen oder
aus dem
irgendwie Netzwerk oder
wie auch immer von irgendeinem Sensor.
Und dann kompiliere ich das
und dann verteilt sich das auf das
System oder wie wird
das aufgeteilt?
Genau, richtig.
Also ich definiere dann sozusagen in meinem Programmcode
mehr oder weniger diesen Abarbeitungsgrafen, würde ich sagen.
Also ich habe meine ganzen Operatoren,
da kann ich immer, am schönsten ist es mit Lambda-Funktionen,
kann ich die Funktionalität so reinpflanzen.
Das heißt, meistens sind diese Operatoren schon vorgefertigt
und wenn ich aber ein Map habe,
dann gebe ich halt die Funktion mit der Gemap-Wert rein
oder wenn ich irgendwas aggregiere,
dann gebe ich halt die Funktionen rein,
wie dann aggregiert werden soll.
Und das wird dann halt irgendwie genommen
und diese einzelnen Operatoren werden dann eben verteilt
auf unterschiedliche Systeme, unterschiedliche Server,
wo halt dieses Flink zum Beispiel schon installiert ist
und das dann entgegennimmt und ausführt.
Da ist dann quasi mein gesamter Programmcode
auf jedem einzelnen Node drauf
und der kriegt dann gesagt,
spring mal zu diesem Lambda
und führ mal nur dieses Lambda aus,
weil die anderen Schritte habe ich auf der Kiste
vorher schon mal gemacht oder mache ich gerade parallel woanders?
Nee,
jeder Operator wird einzeln ausgeführt
beziehungsweise teilweise
ist eine Optimierung halt das ganze
Operatorketten, die halt
keine Verzweigung
zu Operatoren auf
anderen Maschinen haben,
dass die gemeinsam ausgeführt werden.
Aber das kann man
sich so vorstellen, dass dann einfach
pro Operatorinstanz
irgendwo ein Thread ist, der nur
Operator darstellt und
Events
entweder lokal entgegennimmt oder
das Netzwerk entgegennimmt, abarbeitet
und zum nächsten Punkt,
der irgendwie konfiguriert ist vorher, den man
dann von der Hauptmaschine gekriegt hat, von dem
Master irgendwie,
denn das weiß man halt immer dann,
was sozusagen der nächste Operator
ist und wo der liegt, wo er hin muss.
Interessant.
Super, fun.
Achso, ich habe übrigens
ganz kurz zurück zu Thema Nummer 1.
Noch ein Link, den ich schon ums gehauen.
Das war jetzt ein schöner Blogpost von einem Typen,
der sehe ich gerade in der URL, der ist schon
von 2013.
Functious Applicatives and Monads in Pictures.
Der hat mir sehr, sehr gut
geholfen, um da ein paar Sachen zu verstehen.
Der ist große Klasse.
Kann man durchlesen.
Was wir auch bestimmt schon irgendwann mal erwähnt hatten, was ich allerdings auch
sehr hilfreich fand, war
Functional Programming
Jargon in JavaScript.
wo dann einfach erklärt wurde, was eine Monade ist,
ist quasi was, was eine Map-Funktion und eine Flat-Map-Funktion ist.
Ist das, die wir im Auto auf dem Rückfahrt vom vorletzten Kongress gelesen haben?
Ja, genau, wo ich dann gesagt habe,
das müssten wir mal auf andere Sprachen übertragen.
Das stimmt für einmal im Plan.
Witziger Side-Note hier zu Frank McSherry's Timely Data Flow.
Er hat dann auch noch ein eigenes,
möglichst effektives Serialisierungsformat erfunden,
wo die Serialisierung auch massiv
unsafe ist. Also ich werde auch nochmal verlinken
den
Talk beim
Bay Area Rust
Meetup, wo er über Timely
Dataflow geredet hat, wo er gesagt hat,
die anderen brauchen alle riesen Serverfarm.
Ich möchte es erstmal auf meinem Laptop zu laufen
kriegen und hat es dann so gebaut.
Er hat ein Serialisierungsformat
gemacht, was halt möglichst unsafe ist.
Möglichst unsafe ist das Ziel.
Das heißt Abomination.
Bestbürkiger Titel.
Aber ich finde es schön, dass wir aus den
Pix-Ros nochmal
zurück zum Hauptthema
gekommen sind. Ja, stimmt.
Ich versuche mal was ähnliches. Ich hatte ja wie gesagt nicht sehr viel
Zeit, aber
in den letzten Wochen ist,
da komme ich jetzt zu meinem Dayjob zurück,
ich mache ja hauptberuflich
vornehmlich TypeScript, da ist vor kurzem
Version 2.8 rausgekommen
und das Schöne ist, dass die an dem Type-System,
was sie ja bauen, um möglichst statisch die Eigenschaften
von JavaScript doch recht gut ausdrücken zu können,
haben sie in Version 2.8 Conditional Types hinzugefügt
und das ist auch, da fallen einem nicht immer sofort Sachen ein,
aber ich finde auf der Release-Seite, auf den Release-Nodes
haben sie ein wunderschönes, einfaches Beispiel,
wo man das nämlich einfach nehmen kann, um damit
statische Evaluierungen zu machen,
nämlich, wenn ich einen Typen vom Typ T
habe, also ein
Typename vom Typ T habe und
T, das ist quasi einfach eine Hilfaussage
im Typ, und T ist übrigens
vom Typ String, dann ist mein Typ
gleichzeitig der String String, weil man
nämlich in TypeScript Typen
als Stringliterale
als Typen
haben kann. Das ist jetzt ein bisschen
blöd, aber in dem Beispiel sieht man das eigentlich ganz gut
und im Endeffekt, was das macht, ist,
dass du eine statische
Typ-zu-Typ-Namen-Mapping
damit nachimplementiert kannst. Also du kannst
damit quasi den
Type-of-Operator
von JavaScript,
der dir einfach, wenn du was reingibst,
den Typen davon als String hinschreibt, kannst
du in TypeScript damit bereits nachimplementieren.
Und das noch für andere eigene Typen
machen, das ist ziemlich cool.
Okay.
Also Conditional Types
gibt es jetzt auch in JavaScript.
Interessant.
Die Tabs gut.
Die Tabs gut alles macht.
Sehr schön.
Ja,
zum
meinem letzten, jetzt muss ich ihn aber auch irgendwie in die Schiene
zwängen, das hat in meiner Meinung nach
gar nichts mit dem Thema zu tun.
Mach mal einen, der überhaupt nichts damit zu tun hat.
Bezeichnen wir ihn auch als kleine
funktionale Anwendung. Es hat einen Input und es hat
einen schönen Output und der Output ist sogar eine Art Stream.
Und zwar ist das ein kleiner
Service, dem gebe ich als Input Text
oder eine URL und der Output
ist ein Podcast-Feed.
Die haben genau das nachgebaut, was ich mir von der Weile
mal gewünscht habe, beziehungsweise die haben das gebaut,
bevor ich mir das gewünscht habe, aber zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ich mir
das gewünscht habe oder angefangen habe, selber das
zu implementieren, mein Wunsch, wusste ich noch nicht, dass
dieser Service existiert. Moment, was hast du dir gewünscht?
Ich wollte
meine Reading-List, die für mich
ein Friedhof an Artikeln ist,
die ich lesen wollte,
zu formatieren zu einem Podcast-Feed,
den ich hören kann, wenn ich gerade unterwegs bin,
weil ich ja noch nicht genug Podcast-Server
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das unterbringen möchte, aber es klappt schon ein bisschen irgendwie.
Und zwar sollte der, weil ich
gute Text-to-Speech-Engine
finden, die das kann. Und da hat
mich Sebastian auf Twitter zu
irgendeinem Blogpost geschickt, wo
Google diese jetzt betitelte
WaveNet vorgestellt hat, wo sie durch
ganz viele Machine Learning Magic richtig verdammt
gute, beeindruckende Text-to-Speech-Engines
gebaut haben, die echt
beeindruckend klicken. Also ich kann gar nicht
beschreiben, klicken einfach fast wie ein Natural Language.
und ich habe diesen Service irgendwann entdeckt,
nachdem ich wieder angefangen habe, das selber zu basteln,
die genau das macht. Du gibst denen einfach
einen URL oder Text oder sogar
keine Ahnung, eine EPUB kannst du
hochladen oder eine PDF, wo halt Text steht
und die wandeln das um
durch deren Text und Speech Engine, die die
Mittagrückte anbinden, in eine Audiodatei
und wenn du möchtest, auch in einen persönlichen Podcast-Feed
von all den Dingen, die du da reinpipst.
Haben auch so tolle kleine Features gemacht,
wie was ich auch in meinen Service mit einbauen wollte,
wie wenn du dir einen YouTube-Link gibst, dann nimm dir einfach
die Audiospur von dem YouTube-Video.
Auch das geht wunderbar.
Und habe ich auf Twitter angeschrieben,
das Einzige, was ich jetzt noch wünschen würde, wäre hier Support für
Google's Wavenet. Ja, arbeiten wir gerade dran.
Ja, nice. Super cool.
Jetzt musst du aber noch sagen, wie es heißt.
narrow.co
N-A-R-R-O.C-O
Kommt wahrscheinlich von
Narrate, gehe ich mal von aus, der Name.
Und die haben jetzt in der Beta, kannst du
jetzt Google's Wavenet benutzen. Ich habe es jetzt mal
probiert. Das klingt einfach so fantastisch.
Ich liebe diesen Service. Super, super cool.
Das ist quasi Pocket für vorlesen lassen.
Genau. Klappt halt nur für so
30% der Artikel meiner Readinglist, die halt
keinen Code beinhalten, weil dann
wird das Vorlesen ein bisschen arg problematisch.
Das willst du halt lieber
virtuell lesen. Ich muss dazu geben, dass ich
ab und zu von Pocket auch die Vorlesefunktion
mal benutze und das wird dann echt witzig, wenn du dir
Code vorlesen lässt. Wenn das Problem
jemand sauber löst, nämlich
Code vorlesen, also das kannst du ja nicht mal selber,
das wäre schon mal ein riesiges.
Ich meine, das kannst du ja auch einfach nicht verstehen.
Ich meine, selbst wenn du das gut vorlesen lassen kannst,
verstehe das mal durch Zuhören, was da eigentlich steht.
Das ist ja einfach nicht drin.
Das wirst du visuell vor dir haben.
Springen.
Ja, aber da wo es klappt,
ist das echt super.
Probe es mal aus, das ist echt richtig cool.
N-A-R-R-O.C-O
Genau.
Haben uns kein Geld gegeben.
Die nehmen Geld von dir, wenn du...
Als Ausgleich.
Immerhin bist du nicht das Produkt.
Nee, das stimmt.
Hoffe ich.
Also ich meine, dadurch, dass ich die Google Spray-Fnet nehmen,
was von Google gehostet wird,
reicht natürlich den Kram an Google weiter.
Also so ein minimales Beispiel hatte ich auch mal selber
implementiert, weil ich nämlich von irgendwem ein Hörbuch
irgendwo Umwege
bekommen hatte und mir das auf meinem
Handy abspielen wollte, ohne das
alles zu übertragen und hatte dann in PHP
ein einfach
LS,
wo die Dateien mussten
durchnummeriert sein und mir daraus ein
Podcast-Feed als Server genannt.
Witziger Fuckaround, finde ich.
super cool.
Damit hatte ich quasi Audible bereits
erfunden.
Audible, diese fünf Zeilen
PHP.
Das ist der ganze Service.
Es gibt viele so Services, wo ich mir, als sie
rausgekommen sind, wo ich mir gedacht habe,
so ein, damit sind die jetzt
schweinereich geworden. Ich habe mich tierisch
geärgert. Ich weiß, dass wir irgendwie vor ein paar Jahren
schon mal über so ein Konzept geredet haben.
Ja, Jabber ist geil.
Ich weiß nicht, man hat ja glaube ich irgendwo
einen Vortrag über Jabber gehalten. Wir hatten hinterher drüber gequatscht.
Aber es ist halt nicht zugegnig.
man müsste irgendwie das aufs Handy bringen
und man könnte ja als Identifikation
einfach deine Handynummer
mein Service-Name
als Jabber-ID
haben und
ja, WhatsApp ist für wie viele
Milliarden von Facebook gekauft worden?
Das war eigentlich genau ursprünglich
nur das.
Übrigens in Erlangen implementiert
WhatsApp.
Er war auf eJabber-ID aufgebaut?
Falls wahrscheinlich auf eJabber-ID aufsetzt.
Okay, was ja.
Also hätten wir mal
die Vorlesung.
Kann man nichts machen.
In dem Sinne, also wenn ihr
jetzt gerade coole Business-Ideen hattet,
während ihr diesen Podcast gehört habt,
bitte bedenkt, dass ihr für Ideen,
die ihr während des Hörens
dieses Podcasts hattet, Alimente an
akronisierbar abtreten müsst.
Das steht in den Terms of Use.
Oder zumindest bitte dankend erwähnt,
wenn ihr dann reich werdet, weil ihr
von Amazon gekauft wurdet.
So wie bei Instagram, alles was du
reinstellst, gehört dann Instagram
von den rechten Herren
Das war schon bei ICQ in den AGBs
Alles was du überprüft
Alles Sachen, die einfach
hier auch total illegal sind
in der Theorie
aber keinen Sturz, mal gucken ob
Datenschutzgrundverortungen
welches Thema sie jetzt nicht anschneiden
sich das hoffentlich alles ändert
Also darüber reden wir dann das nächste Mal mit dir
Ja, zum Beispiel
Machen wir doch die DSGVO anschneiden, finde ich gut.
Nehmen wir jetzt gleich im Anschluss auf einfach.
Wir haben es ja erst 23 Uhr.
Machen wir es beim nächsten Mal.
Also in dem Sinne,
vielen Dank fürs Zuhören. Das war
Folge 017
von Akronomisierbar
mit Gast Marius Melzer
heute.
Ja, vielen Dank, dass ich hier sein konnte.
Vielen Dank fürs Kommen. Das war super interessant.
Sehr gut, auf jeden Fall. Und die nächste Folge
in eurem Podcatcher beginnt in
3, 2, 1